what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
all right members of the round core I am
I'm nervous about this
I'm nervous about running over Geoff
Johns Green Lantern rebirth because
there's yeah there's so much history
here I mean this is one of those
beautifully written stories that I've
seen a long time just like a history
standpoint I mean this from the
standpoint of a person that loves
history and comic books there's so much
here so because of the fact that there
is a lot we're gonna do two things one
I'll defer you to my video on how Jordan
explained where you'll find a lot of the
backstory there but we're also gonna do
for those of you guys that just don't
have the time to watch that whole video
we're gonna kind of cross that bridge as
we get to it when it comes to like these
different aspects of Hal Jordans history
but the first thing we do here is we
really just kind of pick up with with
Kyle Rayner actually crash landing on
earth and coming out of the Sun now the
cool thing about this is when it comes
to the different Green Lantern's that
we've had at least up to the point of
Green Lantern rebirth by Geoff Johns
Conrade er is the new kid on the block I
mean he's still the newest one I
wouldn't go as far as to say you know
that he's he's reading around the ears
but I would go as far as to say that
he's just he's the newest guy I mean
really that the chronology in terms of
the different Green Lantern's as they
were introduced was of course Alan Scott
you know the one who's introduced her in
the Golden Age followed by Hal Jordan
Guy Gardner Jon Stewart and then Kyle
Rayner what a creatures some really
compelling things too it's just you know
a lot of the themes that have been
wrapped up and it kind of been left
hanging or effectively being wrapped up
actually by by geoff johns himself but
you know with Colerain are getting here
his ring has really seems to have been
usurped or at least drawn of almost all
of his power but then he also tells
these two people who discover him fear
has a name fear has an actual name now
at this point we jump to Carol Ferris
now something to keep in mind here is
that there was a point prior to Jeff
Jones run on Green Lantern where Carol
Ferris was a star sapphire she was d
star sapphire the difference is that as
far as I'm aware of the star sapphires
it was only it was it was like one star
sapphire there wasn't like a whole group
of them like what Jeff jobs did but it
was really more of like a position a
person was appointed to and imbued with
the power of the star sapphire as
opposed to a person who picked up a ring
and ran with it but it's part of do you
see wrapping up a lot of this Green
Lantern mythos with Hal Jordan they
really just like remove the star
sapphire element of Carol Ferris and
just kind of return her to her normal
human form now of course what she's
really talking about here is the idea
that Ferris Air Force Base is really
kind of defunct here that you know it's
really kind of just
sitting down and saying okay hey guys
you know here is Carol Faris's you know
her stomping grounds fairs air force
base yeah the cool thing about this is
the Jeff Johnson's gonna run over a lot
of this stuff which is gonna make it
easy for us but like any great story
especially a story written by Jeff jobs
it's really just kind of like hey guys
here are the here's here's the bricks
that we're gonna be using to build this
house here's the brick here's the mortar
here are the auger Randy used to tear a
hole in the ground here's the bush hog
who we're gonna use to tear up all the
grass you know here's like here's all
the tools that we need to build this
great big huge massive house and it
comes together really well now this
point we jump to the Bronx New York City
and we pick up with Jon Stewart and Guy
Gardner now Geiger and I want to talk
about for a second because when it comes
to his character there are two kinds of
people there are the people who don't
like Guy Gardner and there are the fans
who are militant about Guy Gardner
woe betide the poor soul who runs up on
a guy gardener fan and it's like hey man
Guy Gardner sucks like those fans will
freak they'll lose their minds but
rightfully so historically in terms of
how he's been depicted this is what I
kind of wanted to wait to get into the
history of this historically in terms of
how he's been depicted Guy Gardner is a
direct reflection of DCs desire to kind
of revamp and change up a lot of the
Green Lantern mythos the reason for this
is because back in the day back in the
you know 1950s when Hal Jordan first
showed up he was it was cool he was
super huge it was a great big deal
because the the only Green Lantern we
had before him was Alan Scott and his
powers were tied to mysticism
they weren't tied to like you don't know
range that were created by the guardians
of the universe how join was a
reflection of DCs desire to tap into the
sci-fi element of comic books that had
made sci-fi comics so popular roll those
over into DC and then reinvigorate
superheroes at comics Barry Allen was
the first step that was taken to do that
very Alan are the reason why he's so
important is because he literally
reinvigorated interest in comic book
superheroes if Julius Schwartz had not
created Barry Allen and introduced him
in DC showcase number four I think it
was uh I doubt that we would have the
kind of second Renaissance of
superheroes that we had in the 1950s but
with with Hal Jordan showing up it was
like spacefaring adventures and it was
really cool the problem with this was
that by the Midnight's at the bar I
guess really by the late 1950s this got
more Weisinger taken over the world of
Superman and he was like well let's just
have Superman go into space well now you
know fans were kind of conflicted
because on one hand you had Hal Jordan
who was kind of cool but he was nothing
when it came to the strength of the
power of Superman and then you had
man in space and so why would you read
stories about Hal Jordans face when you
read stories about Superman in space and
so how Jordan's comics began to fell to
the you know fall to the wayside and
began to sort of disappear now there was
a point where DC rolled him over
alongside Green Arrow we'll talk a
little bit more about that here in a
minute once we get to Oliver Queen but
you know because of the fact that Hal
Jordans comics really just failed to
maintain a reader base of any real of
any real substance and number during the
the 50s and 60s going into 1968 I think
it was DC said okay well let's try with
the idea of getting rid of Hal Jordan
and replaced him with a new Green
Lantern called Guy Gardner now after Guy
Gardner was introduced over the years uh
he was hot-headed you know he was he was
really impulsive but that element of his
character drew fans in because the
question was you know what's gonna game
you know what's a guy Gardner going to
say or do this time you know especially
when we saw crisis on Infinite Earths
coming around and we saw him become one
of the founding members of Justice
League International he was constantly
butting heads with Batman you know
because he's like yeah Batman but your
old hat man you know your old school
what we need is a new school leader we
need a guy that understands the streets
understands how things work you know and
it was very rare that he would just put
up with people to be you know to
pardon my language but you know to be
quite frank it was rare that he would
put up with people's nonsense so because
of that he really grew as a popular
character but again because of the fact
that Hal Jordan just wasn't resonating
because of the fact that the Green
Lantern mythos just wasn't sticking
despite the fact that John Stehr was
introduced in 1971 well the time we got
around to the late 1980s to the
mid-1990s eventually do you see was like
you know what let's just get rid of Hal
Jordan isn't in his entirety and let's
just kind of like revamp the Green
Lantern mythos part of this was looking
at Guy Gardner and saying okay let's
take him away from being a Green Lantern
so we effectively lost his connection to
the Lantern Corps he became a yellow
answered for a while and then we saw a
story where he basically they kind of
went back and they touched him said well
he's you know he's part of some alien
race I don't know what it's called a
starts with a V um but they said you
know he basically has like minor
shape-shifting he can grow to a certain
size he kind of you know changes his
body's physical structure to allow for
new powers and abilities and he's sort
of calling himself warrior and that's
where he stayed he never really moved
beyond that because you know by that
point in time you had Jon Stewart who
was you know a major Green Lantern
because of the fact that fans were
coming from the Justice League cartoon
show and they wanted to see Jon Stewart
as a Green Lantern you had Kyle Rayner
who had already been introduced and
we'll get to him a little bit you know
here in a second so once we get to the
return of Hal Jordan but it was really
just this idea that you know guy garner
was just kind of left out in no-man's
land for a time and he basically just
sort of stayed there and so DC never
really did a whole lot with his
character now again with it with the two
of them with Guy Gardner and Jon Stewart
kind of going at it with one another one
of the things that I hope you notice
here is the huge difference between the
two guy Garner's impulsive he's reckless
he's hot-headed Jon Stewart's very
composed Jon Stewart's very calm now his
own experiences have led to that his own
experiences led to him being composed
you know always looking to the future
always wanting to make sure that he
makes the right decision sometimes
overthinking the decisions that he makes
but you know they're like oil and
vinegar but they also worked so well
together
the kicker about this is Jon Stewart
also recognizes that when it comes down
to it when all else fails if there's any
guy that you want in your corner
it's Guy Gardner because he's got it
where it counts when it comes down to it
what it's like look god we got to stop
screwing around we got to get down to
serious business he will be in your
corner and he'll fight to the bitter end
and that's one of the reasons why fans
love him so much but you know continuing
on we basically pick up with the arrival
of Hal Jordan I let me to point out here
is this is how Jordan Spector and this
is really when we start to get into a
lot of the of the interesting things
about this because when he arrives and
he starts talking to Jon Stewart and NDI
Gardner immediately people started
descending on him spilling their deepest
secrets you know people had cheated on
their taxes you know guy go there's like
hey I cheated on my taxes people are
saying that basically you know had
affairs I mean they're really just
spilling their deepest darkest secrets
and Hal Jordan effectively has to bail
out now we'll find out why here in a
minute but at this point we jump over to
Oliver Queen now Oliver Queen has
actually spent a time with a girl named
Mia and Mia was kind of like this newest
iteration of speedy by the time this era
of comics came around or at least she
was when when she had first popped up
Mia was a girl who had actually had a
pretty dark past she was more or less
kind of cast out onto the street she was
eventually forced in a child
prostitution and then when she was
discovered by Oliver Queen he basically
just kind of like took her you know
under his ward in the same way that
Batman took you know Dick Grayson and
Jason Todd after him you know brought
them in under under his hair and taught
her everything he knows so she can be a
contributing member of society the
problem with all this is that you know
while they're doing whatever is they
and it's their training and exercises
and so on and so forth um they're
basically ambushed by by black hand now
this is a really really funny situation
here because black hand was always like
a minor villain I mean he was never like
a like a huge guy he was never like oh
my god black hands here the Justice
League is civil you know it was it was
never anything like that you know it was
like all black hands whatever you know
but what he does is he basically breaks
into the home of Oliver Queen and he
steals the ring of Hal Jordan Oliver
Queen of course intervenes but then we
suddenly have Hal Jordan arriving here
as the spectre now this is why I waited
to bring this up because for a lot of
people who are getting into Jeff Jones
real Anton rebirth the question is how
does the spectre fit into this you know
how do we get from point A to point B
what's the connection here well the
connection here is a story called
Emerald Twilight as well as zero hour
and then final night because of the fact
that Hal Jordan just wasn't selling that
well and the realm of comics with
Superman basically being killed off DC
said well you know what let's use this I
mean if we're gonna kill off Superman
then you know let's let's get rid of Hal
Jordan let's use this as a chance to
basically have like an unofficial crisis
or we begin to sort of get rid of these
heroes that we really can't do anything
with the problem was that Hal Jordan was
the Green Lantern I mean you know he was
the the most popular of all the Green
Lantern's despite the fact that his
comics didn't sell that well and so
because that DC couldn't just kill him
kill him that is basically had to put
him on the back burner and so what they
did is they said okay during the during
the events there are the fallout of the
Death of Superman called reign of the
Superman in addition to cyborg superman
basically being the main bad guy we're
gonna have him pair up with a villain
named they're gonna destroy Coast
City Hal Jordans gonna come back find
out his city in his home and everybody
he knows has ever been destroyed and
then he's gonna recreate it the
guardians of the universe are gonna
chastise him for it and then in his
grief he's basically going to lash out
and he's going to destroy all the Green
Lantern's and he's gonna kill all the
Guardians of the Universe now during
that time he basically started calling
himself parallax because back during the
events of Emerald Twilight parallax
prior to Geoff Johns run was just a name
that Hal Jordan gave himself you know
it's just I'm calling myself parallax
now and it was kind of cool at the time
because it seemed pretty edgy but he
essentially just kind of destroyed his
Green Lantern ring was like you know I
have absolute power now I don't need to
be a Green Lantern I'm better than all
of them took on this this immense amount
of energy and in doing so
gantlet reassemble his ring and it gave
it to Kyle Rayner and that's where Kyle
Rayner
came in as the next screen lanter so
again it was really kind of DC setting
the stage and saying okay let's go ahead
and do this soft reboot now following
Emerald Twilight DC also sat down and
said okay we have a lot of continuity
issues after crisis on Infinite Earths
but we only have one universe right now
so let's basically just blink the
universe out of existence bring it back
and after the universe comes back we'll
give the fans a chronological timeline
of when events took place you know we'll
have sort of these continuity issues fix
different things like that that was
called zero hour crisis and time but
because of the fact that Hal Jordan was
still kind of around he was still kind
of there just lingering in the
background DC was looking at the sales
of green lantern under Kyle Rayner and
they were looking at the former sales of
green lantern under Hal Jordan they said
which one is more popular well at the
time the Kyle Rayner was creating
constructs that people had never seen in
a Hal Jordan coming before you know Kyle
Rayner was creating these giant robots
these really intricate things because
the backstory of his character was that
he was an artist he wasn't just some Air
Force pilot who was relatively
unimaginative and so because of that his
comics sold out sold Hal Jordans by
leaps and bounds so DC donut said okay
fine time for Hal Jordan to go and so
they launched a story called final night
where Hal Jordan basically just
sacrificed his life to reignite the Sun
and that was it he do that would that
was the end of Hal Jordan we never
really saw or heard from him again
following this DC basically merged him
with a being called the spectre and then
they said okay let's go ahead and start
bringing it back now there was a little
bit of time you know while this happened
but as the spectre he just kind of
appeared you know occasionally as the
judgment of God and he would carry out
these things again DC is kind of keeping
him on the back burner and so that's why
he appears here as the spectre because
he's basically possessed by the spirit
of God's judgment and all it really does
just go around and impose God's judgment
on people proportional to what their
acts are of course what he says here
with black hand is you know you you're
essentially a thief and because of that
we're gonna burn away the one thing that
you value most we're taking your hand
and so what it literally just turns his
hand to asteroids it to coal you know
and burns it away and so you know again
with Oliver Queen because of the fact
that Oliver Queen and and Hal Jordan had
shared a publication together they had a
lot of crossover they had a lot of you
know events that happened between the
two of them especially with things like
snow birds don't fly we was revealed
that Roy Harper was addicted to heroin
because of that um the oh the two of
them have a lot of history together so
really if anybody knows how to earn the
best year it's probably you know Oliver
Queen and it's gonna be a pretty
kortnee character here but more so than
him I think it's really gonna be Kyle
Rayner as the most important but you
know while Jon Stewart and Guy Gardner
spending time a guy gardeners bar called
the Warriors it was really kind of this
cool hangout similar to like nowhere
from from DC or from Marvel Comics
except it was station on earth you know
his powers basically kind of begin to go
awry his powers begin to go insane to
the point that he doesn't really seem to
be able to control him lets off a
massive amount of energy and what seems
to be an explosion now following this we
basically pick up with you know just
some pilot fly across or you know fly
over crow City when he comes to the
realization that Co city has effectively
been recreated it's been reformed again
now it's not teaming with life it's not
like everybody's there but the buildings
the streetlights you know a lot of the
things that people recognize are there
and so because it's the question is
what's going on what's happening now
jump me back to Guy Gardner uh you know
in the Justice League of America
watchtower he's you know being being
held by you know dr. midnight by John
Jones you know Superman Batman I mean
they're all they're trying to figure out
what's going on and what they do is they
come to the realization that his body
just kind of seems to be restructuring
itself you know his body seems to be you
know reforming for whatever reason that
alien DNA that was so prevalent there is
funny against its human DNA now in truth
this is this is geoff johns basically
you know doing this thing where his body
is effectively being purified so he's
going back to just human you know human
guy gardner and setting the stage for
him to return you know to being a green
lantern but more so than that we pick up
with with the flash meeting with Aquaman
now the crazy thing about this is keep
in mind this is not Barry Allen this is
Wally West flash and you know as they're
going through Co City what we find out
is that one of the buildings that
Rockets the building that's currently
constructed here is a building where the
address is 22 C view the reason why this
matters is because this was the home of
of Hal Jordans old apartment and so the
the inclination that's being sent off to
Batman at least what he's picking up in
terms of what's going on in Co City is
that for whatever reason how Jordan is
going through and just restructuring all
points of his life which basically tell
everybody that Hal Jordans coming back
now the reason why this is a huge deal
is because remember the last time the
Justice League saw how Jordan he was
trying to kill them all as you know as
parallax he was trying to wipe them all
out and so it's like oh my god you know
if Hal Jordan is coming back and his
parallax is coming back it means he's
probably gonna try to wipe out the
universe again or at the very least they
simply just don't trust or at least
man doesn't trust him now switching
focus here Jeff Jones puts a lot of
emphasis on on Jon Stewart Jon Stewart
is is a guy whose loyalty is of the
extreme and the suicide once Jon Stewart
believes that you're a person worth
standing up for
he'll stand up for you no matter what
goes on and this is what he does with
Batman you know Batman is like we can't
trust Hal Jordan he's bad-mouthing him
left and right Jon Stewart steps up and
says enough is enough you know like
you're going to have respect for Hal
Jordan the reason why is because as
Batman he exists based on fear in order
for anybody to believe that he's
legitimate they have to be afraid of him
but Hal Jordan as a Green Lantern his
entire purpose is to fight fear and so
if he's resistant to the fear that
Batman puts off or at least to the
persona of the Batman throws off then in
the eyes of Hal Jordan Batman is just a
billionaire who's still sad that his
parents died that's all Bruce Wayne is
too Hal Jordan I mean how Jordans still
respected him to a degree but in you
know when it comes down to hero versus
here what do what each one stands for
you know Jon Stewart sees through Batman
skies how Jordans saw through Batman
skies you know anybody who had to fight
willpower forever literally just to
maintain their abilities saw right
through Batman's guys he was just a guy
who was super smart dress up as a bat
and had to face off against a crazy guy
who dresses the Joker every once in a
while so again you know with this with
this little bit what we end up doing is
you basically pick up with with Hal
Jordan coming across Carol Ferris now
this is just a quick little thing you
know where he basically reintroduces
himself to her it's really just kind of
you know again Jeff Jon's setting the
stage is saying hey some bigger things
are gonna be coming but Jeff Jones also
sits down and says hey guys there's a
lot of history here so he really just
kind of runs over the history between
the two now initially you know when how
Jordan talks her he says hey tell me
about the time that we first met and she
says well you know is when you were a
pilot you were working at my dad's
office you know and you know you hit on
me when everybody else was afraid of me
and that kind of thing but no Howard and
says think back further you know the
time that we really first met and this
is again you know really Jeff John
saying hey you know in the youth of Hal
Jordan he first met Carol Ferris when
Carol's father was running an Air Force
Base told Hal Jordans father to continue
piloting a a jet that was experiencing
you know some some technical issues and
then the jet exploded and Howard his
father died now what Geoff Johns is
actually gonna do later on
he's write a story called Green
Lantern's secret origins and that's what
we're gonna kind of comeback for a lot
of stuff for Hal Jordan and I sort of
reinvigorate that and bring things back
up again but again this really gives us
a lot of cool in sign in terms of how to
you know with regards to how we've used
the world you know in saying that for
him his father was always you know a
major focal point of his life and he
always wanted to to basically make his
father proud you know but for him
because of everything that had happened
you know when he became parallax and
after he became the specter his idea is
he needs to find a way back now how
Jordan is being very very you know
cloak-and-dagger here he's being very
mysterious in a lot of different ways
and in fact you know we'll find out why
here in a little bit because we'll learn
this is not actually how Jordan in the
traditional sense instead we essentially
have cetana of the Justice League you
know telling and telling everybody hey
here is where Hal Jordan is located at
now the other half of this is we also
have Alan Scott this is really kind of
cool because Jeff John sits down and
says hey guys remember Alan Scott is not
a traditional green lantern like Jon
Stewart Guy Gardner or Hal Jordan said
his powers are tied to mysticism they're
not tied to rings created by the
guardians of the universe so because of
this I wouldn't say he's not asked
powerful so much as he's just like you
know he's an orange compared to a banana
and so because of this you know he says
look what's going on here is something
that I can't necessarily cope with
because I don't fully understand you
know it is you know how their rings work
all I really understand is my ring is
based in in mysticism and that kind of
thing so again you know because of the
fact that cetana you know DC's major you
know mystical carriage or one of the one
of their major mystical characters
locates Hal Jordan it's basically the
entire Justice League showing up and
responding to it now you know initially
the the Justice League starts to
question him to a degree and we of
course have Hal Jordan you know kind of
converting to the spectrum we learned
that there is this huge inner argument
this huge fight for the soul of Hal
Jordan going on inside his own physical
body you know fighting for assault more
so than that we basically have you know
the the body of guy gardner continuing
to fight itself to the point that the
human aspect of it wins on and so when
is up happening here is the ring of of
Hal Jordan basically splits it
duplicates itself and then it latches on
a guy Gardner and we officially have Guy
Gardner coming back as a Green Lantern
so again this is Geoff Johns saying hey
guys guy gardener's back to being a
Green Lantern again that whole warrior
thing gone like he is a Green Lantern in
the traditional sense as you guys have
all come to know him
the other half of this is again we have
Jeff John's coming along and saying hey
there's a lot more to this picture here
that's why I say this this run is insane
because there's so much that goes on
what we have you know basically Kilowog
showing up here as part of the Green
Lantern Corps meeting with Kyle Rayner
after he had after he had fallen to
earth but we also have gantlet appearing
here and we essentially learned that car
radar coming to earth and leaving the
Sun was designed to you know for him to
be in possession of the coffin of Hal
Jordan that when he had gone to the Sun
when he had sacrificed his life that his
body had remained in stasis pods the the
version that we're basically seeing
running around right now that's this
that's the spirit that's really kind of
like the the spiritual manifestation of
Hal Jordan in terms of how he relates to
the spectre more so than that
we're actually get a lot of backstory
here in terms of you know parallax of
how all that stuff comes into the
equation now this is why I say things
are kind of cool and things run kind of
crazy because you know in the in the
mind of Hal Jordan not only is he you
know does he have the specter latched on
to his body but again he's also fighting
against the spiritual entity of parallax
because of parallax you know persona as
it initially appears here is still very
much a part of who he is and he's
constantly fighting against this darker
side of himself but again geoff johns is
actually coming back or what at least
what he does is he comes back and he
changes a lot of this because we have
Kyle Rayner meeting with Oliver Queen
and Oliver Queen says okay look if
that's the physical body of Hal Jordan
there then who is the Hal Jordan that's
you know out there right now dealing
with the Justice League and what Kyle
Rayner does is he basically you know
he's he's a vector for Geoff Johns to
retcon a lot of the history when it came
to you know yellow and and the Green
Lantern mythos and what I mean here is
that for decades and decades Green
Lantern's were you know they're their
rings were weak to the color yellow and
it was just a yellow impurity that was
the only real explanation that was given
it's the reason why Sinestro you know
back before you know long before really
you know before crisis on Infinite
Earths he had created a ring that was
yellow because it would it was basically
the weakness of the Green Lantern's it's
not any one thing in particular it's
just the Green Lantern's couldn't really
cope against him and so because of this
what Jeff Johnson does is he comes back
it says no no no no parallax is an
actual entity
parallax is an actual being that at the
beginning of time there was this this
sentient organism you know that
basically fed on the fear of all living
things now because of the fact that the
guardians of the universe have become
aware
this parallax entity was wreaking havoc
across the universe they in turn forged
the central power battery and it's one
of the reasons why they created the
Green Lantern's just because of the fact
that you know the Green Lantern's part
powered by willpower would be able to
combat all fear that existed in the
universe but because of the fact that
parallax was inherently fear himself and
because willpower fights against fear
but because as long as there are people
in the universe there will be fear it
was basically impossible to destroy
parallax in the traditional sense and so
what the guardians of the universe did
is they basically locked him inside the
central power battery and kept it
confined there which they in turn used
to go on and create the Green Lantern
core and what Geoff Johns says is this
is the reason why Green Lantern's were
weak to the color yellow not because
it's just some enigmatika elloe impurity
out there somewhere but because much
like dropping you know ink and a bottle
of water all it's going to do is just
kind of eventually move itself out to
the point that it baits the you know it
spreads all throughout every ounce of
water in that bottle the Green Lantern's
were basically infected by parallax not
only that Hal Jordan was the greatest of
the Green Lantern's you know and like a
cold coming on over the course of three
days parallax just kind of began to seep
his way you know seep its way into Hal
Jordan and you know every time he used
the ring and so because of this how
Journal is quite literally being
poisoned by the parallax entity that was
slowly possessing him to the point that
when M will Twilight happen it was the
perfect opportunity for parallax to
seize absolute control and so when that
happened that's what Hal Jordan became
parallax so you know what geoff johns is
saying here is that instead of emerald
twilight simply say that Hal Jordan just
declared himself parallax instead Hal
Jordan was actually possessed by the
parallax entity now in terms of how it
was that parallax entity was able to
escape you know with Hal Jordan going in
and destroying the a central power
battery it was kind of eating that
people were like well how did he get out
you know how did this happen and so what
we end up learning here is that the the
escape of parallax was not arbitrary the
escape of parallax was not accidental
the escape of parallax was actually
engineered by Sinestro himself and so
what this does is this again allows
Sinestro to be introduced as part of
Geoff Johns Green Lantern rebirth he's
really just kind of grabbing all these
different themes and rocking all these
different themes and together now with
regards to Sinestro going against Oliver
Queen and in Kyle Rayner here to be
quite honest I wouldn't go as far as to
say that either one of these guys stand
a chance and in fact Oliver Queen we
know
and and calibrator even says hey look
I'm not really sure I'm ready for this
he can defend but how Rainer is pretty
exhausted and pretty weakened at the
moment and so the idea of him finding
off against one of the greatest Green
Lantern's to have ever existed let's now
turn evil really seems a lot like a
fool's errand and so again you know it's
really just an instance of Sinestro kind
of toying with Oliver Queen toy with
Kyle Rayner as he's going through with
the intention of eventually taking the
body of Hal Jordan with him now on the
other side of this we still have Hal
Jordan battling this entity of parallax
trying to find a way to win out his own
soul but again we also have a guy
gardner we have john stewart coming into
the fray in an attempt to try to free
him now the other part of this is that
because of the fact that the parallax
entity was basically free running it was
just kind of running around it had
seized control of Jon Stewart it has
seized control of Guy Gardner for a time
but eventually we're able to you know to
break free and so in response to this
because of the fact that there are so
many superheroes out there who are
afraid of the return of parallax we
basically have all hands on deck here we
have dr. fate you know we have Superman
Wonder Woman's it's khana Supergirl
Robin we have Superboy cyborg everybody
who can fight is here because in truth
if parallax is coming back it would take
the combined effort of all of them to
really hold off it so it's really just
kind of two different battles happening
in two locations we have Sinestro going
against Kyle Rayner in Green Arrow and
we have the entirety of the Justice
League going against what they believe
to be parallax reborn in the form of Hal
Jordan now the cool thing about this is
that the rings run on willpower but it's
not an easy thing and that's what Geoff
Johns establishes here you know you
can't just pick up a ring and say I have
willpower and then suddenly become a
Green Lantern
it's a mentally exhausting feat this is
proven when Oliver Queen it was able to
use the ring for an instant and summon
an arrow and you know and shoot it at
Sinestro but that's it now of course
Kyle Rayner basically grabs them and
they that is kind of race off just for
the very preservation of their lives but
Oliver asks the question you know is it
that mentally exhausting every single
time he used the ring and Kyle says yes
every single time like it takes practice
but it is a mentally exhausting thing to
maintain such willpower you know
especially when you're going against
overwhelming odds now again you know
what we get here with you know switching
back to Hal Jordan you know what geoff
johns gives us here is this really cool
situation where it's just this inner
battle between house warden dispatch
Durand and parallax not only that we
actually find out that the specter
bonding itself - Hal Jordan was for
purpose the parallax is a wildly
powerful entity that could quite
literally lay waste to the universe the
specter bonding with Hal Jordan was for
the purpose of giving Hal Jordan a
fighting chance to fight off parallax it
was getting him power that he wouldn't
normally have under his own
circumstances now of course we also have
gantlet you know of the guardians of the
universe making an appearance here
coming back basically to try to fight
off you know try to help defend against
parallax but it was really just kind of
Jeff John saying hey look this is why
Hal Jordan became the spectre it wasn't
arbitrary you know wasn't some plot
device it was an effort to literally
keep him alive and so where Hal Jordans
able to fight off the parallax entity
and in the specter basically just kind
of like bales off to go fulfill its role
as a judge of God because of the fact
that it essentially helps Hal Jordan
achieve his goal of getting rid of the
parallax entity from within his own soul
parallax basically emerges with gantlet
under the idea that ya know - made the
case of the spectres power is almost
non-existent in comparison to his own
and so because of this Hal Jordan is
actually you know offered the afterlife
you know he's really kind of greeted
with the athletic the possibility of
leaving and in fact ganthet really kind
of entices him with this you know he's
really kind of like you know follow my
voice yes you know get it go to the
afterlife and Hal Jordan does that but
the reason is not so that he'll die the
reason is that so his spirit will
effectively be cleansed because what Hal
Jordan needs to know is that as a
superhero as a Green Lantern he did all
the right things that the parallax
entity possessing him was not his fault
he was literally just a guy in mourning
you know and and in this morning in this
experience that he had he was in a
position where he was easy to be taken
advantage of and that's exactly what
parallax did and so as he's kind of
transitioning this afterlife experience
he talks with AB and Sewer he talks with
his father he talked to these extremely
important people that play a pivotal
roles in his life and when he emerges he
basically comes out as the Green Lantern
of course Oliver Queen is wearing the
ring trying to use it as best he can but
the ring whisks off of him and when it
does it goes racing to Hal Jordans
physical body and his spirit basically
merges with his body it's it's finally
how to return back to who he was before
and this is Jeff John sang now we're off
to the races Hal Jordan is back let's go
like let's let's do this and it's so
cool because we get this Hal Jordan
versus Sinestro
not a battle for the ages but it's a
great way to have this story go because
the two have been enemies for so long
and it's really how Jordan saying look
Sinestro you know I mean I realize how
capable you are I realize how powerful
you are but I'm fighting for something
greater I'm fighting for friends I'm
fighting for family I'm fighting for
those that I love you know not only that
it's really just you know kind of
Howerton giving us this this speech you
know giving us this beautiful inner
monologue you know where he's saying
things like it's good to have this ring
back again it feels like I'm back to who
I was it feels like I am myself again
it's like waking up out of a dream and
so ultimately you know as he's going
against the nest ro he's actually
successful you know you know with with
help from kyle rayner in defeating
Sinestro and so the idea was that at
least the Col Rayner anyway the idea
seemed to be that Sinestro was basically
destroyed of course we find out that was
not the case the Sinestro was
essentially sent back to the antimatter
universe sent back to court and that was
really kind of the end of the road for
him least for the time being anyway it's
Geoff Johns basically saying he's going
to come back later on but this is also
the first time that we get to see Kyle
Rayner
and Hal Jordan meet in the traditional
sense where Kyle rain of the Green
Lantern meets how Jordan the iconic
Green Lantern now the funny thing about
this is that again Kyle Rayner is a
great Green Lantern but he's new he's
the new guy he doesn't have the
experience he doesn't have the wisdom
and in a lot of ways he doesn't have the
confidence that Hal Jordan had and so
when he sits down you know he says look
I don't know if I'm if I'm capable of
this you know I don't know if I'm the
kind of person that can really be an
effective Green Lantern I don't know if
I'm a person that has what it takes to
overcome great fear and this is why Hal
Jordan is probably the best of the Green
Lanterns not because of us fighting not
because of his ability to create solid
constructs or go against great enemies
it's his ability to inspire people to
follow him because what he tells Kyle
Rayner is you flew from one side of the
universe to the other
you fought Sinestro one-on-one and live
to talk about it
what do you think you've been doing like
I mean you've basically been staring
death in the face and you've been
fighting if anybody here has been
overcoming their fear it's you all you
have to do is realize you've been
overcoming your fear and it inspires
Kyle Rayner and use like let's go and so
he takes off you know with with Hal
Jordan and they basically race off to
you know fight this this guardian of the
year or fight gantlet you know possessed
by parallax and again that really seemed
to be what Katherine was shooting for
was we need to find a way to unite the
Green Lantern's together where at least
left of the court you know we have to
unite Kilowog we have to unite Guy
Gardner Kyle Rayner Jon Stewart Hal
Jordan bring them all together and have
them face off against the parallax
entity and that's exactly what they do
now initially the Justice League tries
to jump in the Justice League tries to
step in and say hey we got to do
something you know we got to become
involved in this in some form of fashion
and you know of course Alan Scott says
something says no you are not going to
have a hand in this and the reason why
is because this is a Green Lantern
affair this is one of the first times
that all these guys are fighting
together since they are really the first
time since Hal Jordan came back how
Jordan needs to remember what it means
to be a Green Lantern he needs to move
or he's capable of and so because of
this you know he alongside Kilowog and
and Jon Stewart and Guy Gardner you know
it's really just kind of genre Jeff John
saying hey guys here is where things are
now here is the Green Lantern mythos
going forward and they faced off against
against parallax and they effectively
banished the entity you know temporarily
of course it's not not a permanent thing
because you know it seems almost
impossible to completely kill him
instead they effectively just kind of
banished him back to the central battery
court and that's really it you know he's
really confined to where he was before
yes it does return the yellow impurity
for a time is how jordan's showing
batman/superman the rest of the Justice
League that yes he's back but he's not
parallax he's here to be a hero he's
here to be a good guy and so again this
is really just kind of Jeff Johnson
setting the stage and saying hey guys
here's where things are gonna go from
this point going forward oh my god Rob
core I'm running I have no I've had no
sleep I'm running on 0 hours of sleep
right now and it's not like it's one of
those things where it's like oh god I
got I got no sleep because I gotta make
videos and it's just like oh god I'm
going through this depressive phase no
no no I'm running on 0 hours of sleep
because I'm reading Jeff Jones Green
Lantern and it's the craziest thing it's
do this this is so addictive because
like I guess like the origin of star
sapphires right now I'm like well I mean
I can read just like a little bit more
right like I can read just like a little
bit more and then I'll go to bed and the
next thing I know I'm halfway through
the first volume of Sinestro Corps war
and it's just like why have I not slept
yet like but it's it's so good it's it's
such an amazing run but here's the deal
so with Geoff Johns Green Lantern and
actually noticed this question was being
asked by a few people when I had posted
the reading order on red and actually
have the reading order for all the
videos that we're gonna do all have the
reading order down in the description or
at least the order of the videos as
we're going to do the
down in the description but one of the
things that I saw as a lot people were
saying hey like when you're loosening
things like Green Lantern core did Jeff
Jones write that no Jeff Jones just
wrote Green Lantern but Green Lantern
core is a companion comic and in truth
well it's not necessary it definitely
helps those of you guys who are coming
from Marvel Comics who read Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers Green Lantern
and Green Lantern Corps is exactly like
that
if you were reading you know everything
in Marvel Comics about the collapse of
the multiverse and all you cared about
was the collapse of the multiverse all
you cared about was planets crashing
into each other and that kind of thing
then you were reading new Avengers you
were following the Illuminati you were
following you know Reed Richards and
Doctor Strange and you know so on and so
forth but if all you cared about is what
the superheroes were doing while the
multiverse was collapsing then you were
reading Avengers but both stories
together made things more cohesive it
made things a lot more intriguing a lot
more interesting and it was it was
richer and it was a fuller story now
officially there came a point where you
know Avengers of New Avengers just
intertwined and you had to read them
both in order to understand what was
going on otherwise you would have gotten
just pieces of the story here and there
and things wouldn't made a sense but
with Green Lantern it's similar to that
but only insofar that the stories don't
really intertwine directly they do when
it comes to events but they're really so
kind of isolated to a degree but we're
actually gonna cover all of them we're
gonna cover both Green Lantern and Green
Lantern Corps but what we're gonna do
here is we're gonna pick out the secret
origin now chronologically secret origin
is not the way we're doing it here this
is actually out of order secret origin
comes much later on in Jeff John screen
Lantern but I really want to cover it
now the reason why is because what it
does is it teases things
Atrocitus the black the the blackest
night prophecy it eases these little
things and then we won't see or hear
anything about them until we get to like
Sinestro Corps war until we get to like
the prelude to Sinestro Corps war and
it's who we get to blackest night we
just get these great little these great
little moments here I think I really
think it makes things more cohesive to
be honest with you guys I think that
that reading secret origin before you
even start the main Geoff Johns Green
Lantern run I think makes things a
little more interesting so again the
cool thing about what Geoff Johns did
here is is under normal circumstances
whenever a writer takes over a story
they take over a character they adjust
things they kind of you know say hey
here's where things say right now but
then if you want to know about why
certain events are taking place will
they just tell you go back and read the
old stuff Geoff Johns does
not do that we can literally start here
and not know anything about green
lantern before Geoff Johns took it over
that's how self-contained it is and
that's how well rid it is and so we're
basically gonna take that approach
there'll be a few times where we
reference things from before Geoff Johns
but on the whole we're not really going
to or actually it's gonna kind of treat
it as though this is the first time
Green Lantern has ever appeared in DC
Comics now of course what this does is
this picks up on the early days of Hal
Jordan is to say when he was a kid and
of course his first introduction to to
Carol Ferris keep in mind the Oh Carol
forces father run a random aircraft
testing program which basically existed
to test out different aircraft for
military use that was the basis behind
of course she had Air Force pilots
different things like that former Air
Force pilots in a lot of ways but when a
new ship was I'm sorry a new plane was
created a new jet was created or
something like that
Phares area would have their pilots test
it out before the military would
actually adopt it and that actually just
kind of makes good sense to be honest if
a plane was dangerous you wouldn't want
to kill your own airforce men because of
that you'd want to kill somebody else's
so it sounds messed up it sounds kind of
it sounds kind of rough but that's
exactly what happens with hal jordan's
father of course you know that the kind
of classic story here then how his
father is killed in a craft that's being
developed now this is going to be a
major focus point for his character Hal
Jordan is going to begin to hate Carl
Ferris because of this in the mind of
Hal Jordan the way his characters want
to grow up the way he's going to
progress his life is going to be
intertwined with the military but this
creates a lot of problems for him
because you know again with his mother
having to sit down at reconcile the fact
that her husband is dead because of the
fact that he flew a plane that was being
experimented on she's terrified that her
children will go the same way you know
and that's what's really cool about this
Geoff Johns is feeding on a lot of
existing concepts a lot of existing
ideas for example the wife of a of a
police officer you know or the husband
of a police officer that loses their
significant other in the line of duty
will tell their children do not become a
cop because they don't want their kids
to be follow the same fate because of
their mind something switches something
changes you know we're previously they
were like yes you know being an officer
is an honor or something on those lines
you know now it's what all it's gonna do
is get you killed and they don't want to
lose any more of their family and the
process that's what's so great about
this is because well Geoff Johns has Hal
Jordans father dying you know of a plane
accident you could change that scenario
out to anything a firefighter you know
a US soldier you could change it for any
number of things and that terrifying
element is still there now of course
what this is done is create a rift
within the family not just with the
guard said to Hal Jordans mom but with
regards to Hal Jordan himself in the
sense that he wants to be an Air Force
pilot he wants to follow his father's
footsteps his older brother it'll kind
of looks at him and says look you're
really not honoring what it is that our
mother is asking for you know his older
brother Jack really shares what seems to
be the kind of struggle that his mother
goes through and he really seems to be
the guy who's kind of stepping into the
role of being the supportive member of
the family because keep in mind the Hal
Jordans bomb is that going through
mental gymnastics right now but at the
same time Hal Jordans younger brother
Jim very much plays or is really adopted
the safe role of his mom you know where
he's like well mom says you shouldn't do
this so don't do that you know mom says
you shouldn't do that so don't do that
and this will actually be a huge part of
Jim's life but for Hal Jordan all he
wants to do is be a pilot and this comes
to fruition you know when his younger
brother Jim goes to take Hauser were to
present on his 80th birthday Hal Jordans
not there only for us to find out that
how Jordan has taken off to join the US
Air Force what this does is bring in a
guy named general stone and general
Stonewall actually see a lot of him in
the first volume of of Geoff Johns Green
Lantern and stone was one of the reasons
why I actually decided to do this secret
origin before we picked up into the main
Green Lantern right in the first place
because I feel like there was a lot of
great backstory that was going on there
but general stone is really just kind of
a Hal Jordans head of the moenay's his
superior you know he's the one that Hal
Jordan is working with and testing these
various planes and and so on and so
forth we also get a little bit of the
first encounter between Hal Jordan and
John Stuart where they basically both
meet each other for the very first time
in a military bar of course they come to
blows again it's just really one of
these interesting situations where
things go back and forth a lot of this
really seems to come to a head though
when Hal Jordan is basically met by the
arrival of Jim of course the two of them
hadn't seen each other for quite some
chod and Jim says mom is sick now the
problem with this for Hal Jordan is of
course his first gut reaction would be
well that I need to go see mom but Hal
Jordans actions of joining the military
were in direct opposition to what it is
that his mother wanted and this is where
both Jack and Jim come into play the
brothers Hal Jordan really Jack more so
than Jim the rows of how Jordan come in
and say look you know you're part of the
reason why mom is here Jim not so that
really doesn't take as much of a heavy
hand in terms of you know Hal Jordans
actions but Jack it definitely says
you're the reason
why she's here you know how George
standing in direct opposition to his
mom's wishes is really a contributing
factor to the fact that she just worried
herself with grief all the time and so
Jim even goes as far as to say look at
the request of Jack because he basically
has power of attorney here you're not
allowed to go see mom so long as you're
in the Air Force now of course this
leads directly into a confrontation
between general stone and and Hal Jordan
so for those of you guys who are always
curious as to how it was that Hal Jordan
was booted out of the Air Force this is
why which one does he sits down and says
look I'm not a quitter
I can't quit what I need to do is
engineer a situation where I get thrown
out now in truth whether you set
yourself up to fail or whether you just
give up it's all the same thing because
your motivation is to leave and this is
really just kind of a kind of how's
Burton's ego coming into play and and
even then you know Geoff Johns really
even draws on that and says yeah like is
Hal Jordans ego that's all it is you
know Howard you wouldn't want to allow
himself to quit he'd rather be fired
from his job and so because of that he
literally punches general stone you know
due the fact that Hal Jordan just kind
of gone off on a joyride you know on a
jet and so on and so forth but of course
this results in him being dishonorably
discharged for the Air Force but as soon
as he goes to visit his mother he's told
she died and this is really where things
begin to kind of split it's almost
always at the time of a loved one's
passing when things begin to sort of go
awry and the reason why I say that is
because usually whenever a loved one
becomes ill to the point where death is
a possibility there's a lot of bonding
that takes place there's a lot of
setting aside with regards to personal
issues personal problems of course we
didn't really see jack or Jim taking
this role but the idea here is that
people usually tend to focus on what's
important the issue with this is that
when that individual passes whether it's
by virtue of grief or whether it's by
virtue of a belief that there's no need
to hold back anymore people begin just
sort of saying things that they wouldn't
normally say or letting out feelings and
they've been harboring for quite some
time and that's the stance that jack
takes you know where Hal Jordan says
look I've sacrificed so much I
sacrificed the Air Force Order so forth
in order to be here with mom I tried to
make it here as I could Jack's response
is you've never sacrificed anything all
you've ever done is what you wanted to
do when mom asked you not to do
something you ran off and you did it you
know your mom said please don't join the
Air Force father you know your father
died yeah while testing a plane please
do not go to the say about his him house
word and took off and did that Jack was
the one that left college to get a job
in order to make sure the family was
taken care of Jack was the one that
tried to keep his mother you
up on her on her two feet tried to keep
her from just kind of boring herself
into the ground they ultimately of
course she had she died of cancer but
the idea here is that hundreds actions
are not those of a person who cares
about individuals outside of himself how
dran actions are of those who only cares
about himself and that's really what
what geoff johns is saying here is that
in the early days of his life pal jordan
was extremely selfish now what this does
is this transitions really to the
moments or to the days leading up to Hal
Jordan becoming a Green Lantern and it
starts out with a bandsaw now of course
avid soar is the death of Bruce Wayne's
parents - Hal Jordan would just say he's
the catalyst by which how Jordan becomes
the Green Lantern with a bandsaw his
character had always just been seen as a
guy who just crash-landed on earth the
reason why that had happened hadn't
really changed too much it was just a
battle led him to that location and the
result it really was it was like a fight
with uh with Sinestro but the result was
of that that incident led to him crash
landing on earth succumbing to his
injuries but before his death sending
its Green Lantern ring out which chose
Hal Jordan what Geoff Johns does here is
change everything Geoff Johns comes out
with the character of Atrocitus assess
that a Buddhist or had essentially lost
his mind over the years or maybe he
gained a little more awareness then he
previously had before the fact remains
that Atrocitus had essentially been
messing with the mind or really kind of
open a bandsaw up to something he didn't
know before that you know prior to the
Green Lantern's coming into existence
this dirty little super the thing that
none of the Green Lantern's knew about
that was that the Guardians had created
the Manhunters now we'll get more into
them as we progress further throughout
the the Green Lantern mythos because vo
the actions of the Manhunters the world
they play it's pretty significant
especially when we get to like you know
really get to revenge of the Green
Lantern's was it war of the Green
Lantern which ever wanted deals deals
with the the lost lanterns that end up
making their return I don't know what
the story's called
and what this does is it shows us that
no one really knew about the Manhunters
before more so than that
Atrocitus been talking about the
prophecy of blackest night about how
basically someone was going to emerge on
earth that was one of --have the way for
the potential death of everything you
know and it was going to lead to a war
of all these different lantern courses
well Abbot's we're never knew about this
but the more than avid sword listen to
the sommore that happens or did his own
investigations the more he began to come
to the realization that Atrocitus was
actually right now keep in mind
Atrocitus is one of the
you know one of the five inversions you
know one of the remaining inversions of
when the Manhunters had gone awry they'd
reach havoc through sector six six six
killing virtually everybody in existence
those who were left formed a group
called the inversion stuff where's
Atrocitus would go on to form a Red
Lantern court of his own but these were
in the early days of his character's
existence or I guess as characters
turned to the darker side of his nature
and the result is that a band saw her
you know and listening to the words of
Atrocitus it's going to become a lot
more cautious that he's basically
started to rely on his ring less and
less now where one would look at this to
say well maybe it's some measure of
protection maybe it's some measure of
preservation it's actually fear Aven
sore is beginning to succumb to fear and
what this is doing is basically
weakening the constructs now we'll find
out how much is his weakened his
constructs later on down the line
but we switch back to Hal Jordan and
switching back to what we actually end
up doing is really we have him as a
person traveling around trying to find
work of course being an Air Force pilot
that was dishonorably discharged from
the Air Force does not do him any favors
somebody else that I hope you notice
here or somebody that I'd like you to
notice is a person by the name of
Franklin Minsky now we had kind of
passed over him a little bit but
Franklin Minsky was was a guy who was
really just kind of a he was a pile that
was carried away with his success he
believed he was a lot better than he was
he was really kind of an a reckless hire
a reckless pilot a guy who would get
carried away with his own skills so on
and so forth you know and believe that
he was amazing and we'll see him you
know later on but for those guys who
were reading read alleged right now
Franklin Minsky was the guy who was
basically saved by Hal Jordan he became
the Green Lantern later on here in a
little while Franklin ski became
obsessed with the Green Lantern thought
he was going to be one he never did and
in Sam Humphreys current run of Green
Lantern's rebirth he became the Phantom
Lantern so that really just kind of
shows you how far back Sam Humphreys is
drawing when it comes to reaching in to
the work that Geoff Johns put in when it
came to the Green Lantern landscape
overall but again you know picking up
with with with house worden trying to
find work the issue here is that he's
basically you know found out that one of
his at least the most reliable contact
the person he was hoping for the most is
actually being bought out by by Carol
Ferris or by Ferris air and so
effectively he or at least it seems like
he's going to be coming under the the
controller lease under the direction of
Carol Ferris but even then how Jordans
still kind of out of work he doesn't
have a job for her sake but I guess what
you back to a bad sore because of the
fact that he's feeling fear because of
the fact that he's falling prey to the
idea that his Lantern ray will fail him
somewhere along the line as the prophecy
of Atrocitus dictates this allows
Atrocitus a brief moment to basically
free himself from the constructs of Abin
sort and in doing so lead to a fight
between Evan steward himself that sends
Evans sure Evan saw his vessel crashing
into the planet Earth now of course
Atrocitus drops jumps out before that
happens but this is why Ivan Sewer
crashed on earth in the first place this
is why he's basically succumbed to
injuries of a mortal nature this is why
he sent his ring out into earth and says
find me a new house for the Green
Lantern of sector to eight one four find
me someone who can undertake this mantle
Hal Jordan is chosen and Hal Jordan
basically becomes Earth's very first
Green Lantern now forced again this
leads into him directly saving the life
of Franklin Minsky and this is where
Franklin Minsky becomes obsessed with
the nature of a Green Lantern now the
cool thing about this is something that
I hope you noticed is that within the
realm of DC Comics Franklin Minsky is
going to be a guy like if you think
about you know the chronology if you
read Sam Humphreys Green Lanterns from
the time that he first gets off this
plane the time that he's saved by Hal
Jordan really up until Green Lantern's
he was everything that you saw that that
whole idea of him just you know working
his body physically you know becoming in
better health different things like that
that all took place while all this was
happening you know he was just in the
background he was just a hidden guy he
was a throwaway character here and it
actually worked out kind of well listen
he also noticed that Hal Jordan is
basically learning about what the ring
does and how it functions you know as he
possesses it and so what he is up doing
is of course he beats Hector Hammond for
the very first time he don't really a
guy who's brought in as a strategist of
sorts for for Ferris air but he also
basically travels and buries the body of
a band sore now this is interesting
because what this means is that of
course how's word recognizes the
sacrifice that Aven su are made you know
what he basically said hey look I'm a
member of a universal police force we
exist to preserve the or preserve order
in the universe to preserve the safety
of all people who reside within you know
do you accept this honor conferred and
recognizes the the kind of
responsibility that comes with the role
of being a Green Lantern but also values
life something that I'd like you to keep
in the back of your head though is this
particular instance where he buries the
body of Gavin sword this is how in-depth
Jeff Joe
because what's gonna happen is there's
gonna be a story kala called Hal Jordan
wanted her or wanted Hal Jordan which is
actually gonna focus on the idea of what
happened with a band sewer and what you
know the the fact that Hal Jordan
received the power ring of a band sort
the whole fallout from from just this
one particular instance but of course
like all Green Lanterns like all
individuals who were newly inducted into
the Lantern Corps
Hal Jordan is basically whisked away to
to OA in order to receive training now
one thing we're gonna learn later on
down the line really getting into the
Green Lantern Corps I think it is great
getting into a Green Lantern Corps
recharge is that just because a person
is chosen to become a Green Lantern
doesn't mean they have to become a Green
Lantern and in fact this is actually
gonna be a really really cool scenario
that's going to unfold
I'm almost boiling think it's really
really cool the way it happened does one
of the things that I did I really really
enjoy but right off the bat Geoff Johns
shows us that when it comes to Hal
Jordan he's a hothead he does not like
being told what to do that's the best
way to put it he has a resistance to
Authority I think is the official term
that's given of course you know he meets
Kilowog for the very first time and this
is one of the reasons why Kilowog is a
fan favorite I mean whether people were
reading Green Lantern before Jeff Jones
took over whether they jumped into Geoff
Johns and it was their first
introduction to the Green Lantern mythos
and to Kilowog fans love Kilowog kusers
fans love Kilowog just because of the
fact that he's got so much personality
but the cool thing about this is that
where it would be so easy to write
Kilowog off it's just like a drill
instructor like well he's just a guy
that teaches real Lanterns how to be
Green Lantern's he's a glorified teacher
the guys got it were accounts and that's
that's one of the reasons why people
love him so much because he's just such
a great guy and in fact when Hal Jordan
meets them for the first time but they
start going at it you know it's really
not necessarily the idea that that Hal
Jordan is seriously trying to injure
Kilowog it's just that Hal Jordan is
like well hey man like let's get to it I
mean this is boot camp then let's get to
it man so they literally start fighting
one another you know and of course
Kilowog comes out on top here but it's
just kind of cool to see them go back
and forth it's cool to see them you know
Canio conflict' as one another in battle
one another now of course transitioning
back to back to earth for a quick second
this basically sees like general stone
and different people discovering this
ship of AB and Sewer and basically
taking the ship of Aven story and the
reason why I'm covering a lot of the
stuff a lot of stuff we could run past a
lot of these things we could just kind
of jump over but the reason why
this is because when we get into Green
Lantern the volume one no fear a lot of
these things are going to come back a
lot of these things are going to come to
fruition and so it's important you guys
understand the basis behind a lot of
these things so that when they do crop
up you won't feel left out you won't
feel left behind but again you know this
also coincide with the fact that a
Atrocitus have still survived and
Atrocitus is making his way out now
Atrocitus traveling across the world is
in pursuit of a guy named William hand
also known as black hand and this is why
I say things are huge does this origin
story it wasn't like you know it was
Geoff Johns was kind of making things up
as he went along this is why I like to
in the origins story first I guess he
was making it up as he went along but I
like to with the origin story first
because it sets the seeds for everything
instead of William hand being somebody
who shows up in vol 1
you know long after grill Howard was the
was a Green Lantern really when Hal
Jordan first came back to being the
Green Lantern after the events of his
whole experience with parallax and her
multi light and so on that instead the
hunt for William hand the Black Knight
prophecy predates all of that by quite
some time so it makes things you know
really interesting and it makes me he's
really really intriguing he said I love
this I love this idea like I'm bad
fanboy I love this whole thing so it's
switching back over here to Hal Jordans
training this is when he really begins
to learn about the the yellow impurity
for the first time now this is something
that I wanted to clear up this is
something that I wanted to rectify right
off the bat with NBC comics right now at
this moment which is to say the present
day because we're secret you know secret
origins takes place in the past and the
president right now we know that the
yellow impurity was really just the
parallax entity inside of this the the
Green Lantern's central power battery
the issue is that at the time at this
point in time when Hal Jordans learned
to become a Green Lantern no one knew
that all they knew was that you know
Green Lantern's are just have a weakness
to the color yellow now the reason why
they had a weakness of the color yellow
is because the parallax entity the the
very entity of fear was basically
creating a weakness within the central
power battery it creates a wave for the
central power battery or at least for
the Green Lantern's to have a weakness
it's it's a tainted access to the to
willpower and so because this it's
basically you know is if you were to
build a building and then you have a hat
you have a key to it you know and you
tell everybody hey look if you want to
access this building you need this key
but then also somebody else later on
down a lot of somebodies would work
against you has a key as well and it was
because you gave it to them somewhere
long line but the idea is that they can
enter that building anytime they want
- and they can basically create ways for
that building to have structural
weaknesses and so on it's kind of a weak
analogy but it's the best I could think
of on the fly ah
but nonetheless though the points kind
of getting across that at this point in
time the the weakness of Green Lantern's
- the color yellow is just believed to
be because it's just the color yellow
now of course what this does is create a
rift in how it's run because it's like
well that's stupid like I mean that's
not an answer like Green Lantern's are
we - the color yellow because it's the
color yellow like that's not an answer
at all like what's the yellow impurity
why is it that the yellow is considered
impure in the realm of Green Lantern's
but Kilowog doesn't have answers to this
no-one has answers to this except for
the Green Lantern's themselves now of
course Green Lantern rebirth which you
know of course we already had that video
uploaded that answers that question
that's Geoff Johns giving us the answer
for why it is that there's a yellow
impurity there but prior to Kyle Rayner
learning the truth about the parallax
entity no one knew that no one was aware
of what was going on and so because it's
what actually is up happening here is we
pick up with Tamar Tamar rain that's how
my way is is a character that a lot of
fans left but he's also someone who
knows who Adams sewer is and this is
when we begin to learn the legacy of
Adam stork how significant a band sewer
was to the Green Lantern mythos avid
sort wasn't just a guy he wasn't just a
random Green Lantern and he died and
it's like whoa man that sucks teal and
his ring got a replaced with like we
don't know who this guy is whatever like
Hal Jordan is stepping into some very
big shoes some very large shoes but
tomorrow a goes to Hal Jordan and says
look you carry the ring of a band sewer
it's important that you know a lot of
what happens sewer knew and he basically
introduces him to the book of OA and
says these are the laws of OA the book
of all everything you need to know about
a green lantern is found here there are
things that you simply just cannot know
about but in this book you will find the
legacy of great warriors past avid sewer
is one of those it's an inning to his
tale a time will come when your tale
will hand and you will be in the book of
OA the time will come when Toma raised
tailwind and he will be in the book of
OA will all be added to the book we will
all contribute to the greater whole that
is the Green Lantern mythos the Green
Lantern landscape so this is basically
tomar a saying that you stand in
something greater than yourself you
stand on the precipice of being part of
something this massive and scale so from
here it's really it's kind of like this
training montage to a degree that Hal
Jordan is learning to become a Green
Lantern he's learning everything that
goes along with that
create constructs you know how it is it
is constructs work in conjunction with
the color yellow
but the cornerstone behind all this
really in the background of Hal Jordans
mind is there's no reason why Green
Lantern's shouldn't be able to use their
power against the color yellow it's just
a color there's no reason it shouldn't
be able to work if there is a reason why
why our rings can't work against the
color yellow then it has to be something
physical tangible it's not a
psychological thing it has to be a
physical tangible thing and if it's
physical and is tangible it can be
overcome and so that's the cool thing
about this is because Hal Jordan right
off the bat is pushing the limits of
what it means to be a Green Lantern he's
questioning everything he's questioning
everything they know he's questioning
everything that he's been taught and so
what happens is we end up picking up
with what seems to be some unknown Green
Lantern learning about the death of a
band sore and the person the question
this person has is why have I not been
told about the death of evidence or why
have I not been told that Aven Sewer has
been killed why am I just now being told
why wasn't it a media well of course the
Rings answer is where you were in the
middle of conflict your focus that need
to be disrupted so on and so forth and
so the question of the the question this
Lantern has is what happened take me to
where it is that heaven sewer died
take me to earth of course this is when
we learned that this particular Green
Lantern is Sinestro and so what this
does is lead into the very first
encounter between Sinestro and Hal
Jordan himself
okay so continuing on with green lantern
secret origin again this is why I say
that Geoff Johns run you know a lot of
the stories that he tells are really
self contained secret origin was
designed to be this updated retelling of
the early days of Hal Jordan as he
became the Green Lantern
you know while he was the Green Lantern
so on and so forth it's really just kind
of this rehashing of things so that's
why I say this is so cool is because if
we take secret origin and we basically
kick off Geoff Johns Reena Lantern run
with secret origin then we create this
totally self-contained cohesive
continuity that doesn't require us to
really know anything before geoff johns
started that's all the reasons why it's
so cool there's a few things we need to
know here in there but of course the
second video really picks up with Hector
Hammond now again Petra Hammond the way
that he's introduced here is as starkly
different from the other way that we saw
him before part of this Hector Hammond
was still you know a bad guy but the way
that he gained his powers was different
the same process was a meteor but the
way it was or I guess the way he came
across was differed it was like in the
woods or something along those lines
what this does is make it a little more
make a little more cohesive make it make
a little more sense in the sense that
because of the fact that Hector Hammond
is basically a private conduct
consultant for Ferris aircraft for
Ferris air when Ferris gets a hold of
the ship or at least when the US Air
Force gets a hold of the ship that Abin
soar had crash-landed and Hector Hammond
is one of the guys who's investigating
it now what geoff johns gives us is
basically the groundwork for what Hector
Hammond will become which is to say in
this instance Hector Hammond is very
abrasive his you know he really sees
things as his way or the highway what we
also find out is that he is not viewed
and by anybody in a good way and what I
mean here is that we're people you know
with the people that he's working with
we're talking about how the engine core
you know is kind of kept closed it's
difficult to access they don't really
know what's inside of it they shouldn't
just crack it open
Hector him and just bust the thing wide
open and when he does he's exposed to
the meteor the meteor energy source and
he's basically endowed with telepathy
and telekinesis it modifies the
structure of his brain that gives it new
powers the problem is that it's not
necessarily something he to control
initially instead what is it happening
is just like anybody in comic books who
dilib who develops telepathy he begins
just you know unintentionally reading
the mind of those around him and what he
learns is that everybody hates him
people consider him weird they get
Citarum strange they consider him
somebody who's just socially awkward
does it have any social skills they just
look at him as it's just an odd fellow
now this is interesting because what
geoff johns does he says
Hector Hammond could have gone two ways
I mean this fraction of a second was a
crossroads he could have taken their
words to heart and you know become
something better than what he was or he
could have just stayed on the path that
he was on now in truth well the path
that he was on his powers were of such a
level that he easily could have just
dealt with all these guys and that's
what he does he lashes out and he kills
them all and and it kind of makes sense
I mean opinions are useless to a dead
man so because of this Hector Hammond
effectively falls down the path of being
a bad guy he falls down the path of
being a villain but was gonna be
interesting about this is that instead
of just you know his powers running
amuck he's gonna harness them pretty
fast
and Geoff Johns is gonna say hey look
this is why Hector Hammond is going to
be a bad guy from this point going
forward now of course every year we pick
up with the return of Hal Jordan that's
one of the cool things here is Geoff
Johns kind of plays fast and loose with
regards to how she would returning to
earth but he does it in a way that makes
sense what Hal Jordan basically says is
that once he was finished with his boot
camp training the ring said you will be
alerted of any extraterrestrial threats
in your sector now you're going back
home and the ranges teleports him back
to earth now of course he comes across
Tom the mechanic if there's air of
course Tom prior to Geoff Johns green
latitude we knew that tom was kind of
like this really close friend of Hal
Jordan and was one who is basically kind
of going through this whole you know the
last will and testament of how George we
talked about our video about carburetor
becoming God what we also find out is
that where Arden Air Force or Arden Air
was this place basically where you know
former pilots existing pilots you know
we're helping to test aircraft with
Ferris air moving in with the intention
of buying Arden air all the pilots have
quit now this is not because of the fact
that it's just viewed as a hostile
takeover it's not because of loyalty to
Arden air it's because of the stigma
that follows Fairs air and this tells us
how deep the death of Hal Jordans father
goes that it doesn't just impact him the
pilots everywhere look at Ferris air and
say that guy took shortcuts Carl Ferris
took shortcuts and when he did it
resulted in the death of an Air Force
pilot nobody wants to fly a death trap
and that's what they're afraid of
they're afraid that the Feres air will
show us a hey guys here's an aircraft
that the the Air Force wants to test
here's another aircraft the Air Force
wants to test and they have they're
afraid they'll have no idea if the time
they go up in the air to test that that
you know whatever that aircraft happens
to be and that will be their last time
nobody wants to go the way of Hal
Jordans father so because of this Carol
Ferris really kind of has to look around
and realize that because of the things
that her father did now she's basically
running a failing business that nobody
wants to come in
Annie oh is is is
great as it is with her being you know a
test flight company of what use is her
company if no one's willing to test you
know aircraft for her company yes so
with the arrival of Hal Jordan this is
kind of cool because this is kind of
this is all of the way the Geoff Johns
does is it's one of these things were
like opposites attract and again they
have a history you know I mean well a
history only insofar as like how Jordan
knew her when she was a kid
but unlike the whole idea of like
opposites attracting and it says it how
Drouin walks in and he basically says
yeah like you know when would Carol when
Carol's like hey are you here to quit
too he's like yep like put my name on a
list of resignations and they start
arguing and bickering with one another
but then this is really when Hal Jordan
starts to let it out and says look you
know the reason why everybody's leaving
is because they don't trust you they
don't trust the name of your family your
dad took shortcuts they're afraid you're
gonna take shortcuts and you're gonna
get somebody killed now one thing to
keep in mind here is that because of the
actions of Hal Jordan rubber he had
basically punched out his superior
officer general stone you know he had
basically been booted out from the Air
Force his desire to fly lasted only so
long as someone who is basically a
friend of the family
we kind of sneak him under the radar
given me how give him a helping hand
here and there what Carol Farris is
offering is the ability to get him back
into the air to officially reinstate him
as somebody who can legally fly aircraft
now Hal Jordans initial response is one
of anger one of outrage because he
doesn't to be part of Ferris air but at
the same time it's an allure that he
can't avoid and that's what's so cool
about Hal Jordan that's one of the
things I love about his character so
much is because Hal Jordan has a power
ring right I mean it only has to do is
slap on his real Antron ring say the
words the charges ring and fly that's
all he has but he could just fly but for
him it's about Jets because Jets have
danger a jet could fail somebody could
crash into him a bird could hit him at
the wrong angle a meteor could come
crashing into the earth that's not big
enough to destroy a planet but certainly
big enough to take out a jet there's any
number of things that could happen that
could put his life in danger it's the
thrill of flying a jet not only that a
Jets been his entire life as it's been
everything that he's that he's known and
so because of that flying with his own
ring is not the same as flying a jet and
in the end flying a jet is something
that he can't leave behind anymore and
so he basically ends up ally yourself
with Carol Ferris now and this why we
switch back over to Atrocitus is why I
say Jeff Jones did so much world
building in the secret origin and is one
of the reasons why I wanted to basically
kind of jump back and do the secret
origin first this is
we start to get really into the idea of
the prophecy of the blackest night prior
to this point it was just well Abin Sur
was told by Atrocitus and the prophecy
of the blackest night we have no idea
what that means of course we know now
the prophecy of blackest night means
that there will be basically a rise of
different Lantern course all those
Lantern cores will go to war with one
another they will all be destroyed there
will be no more light and it'll simply
just be the blackest night that's
basically kind of you know what it means
more or less but what we end up finding
out here is that rubric with Atrocitus
being a survivor of the Manhunters
wiping out sector six six six and being
one of the remaining you know five
inversions of whatever it is because of
that
Atrocitus you know basically consumes
consumes the heart of men he basically
eats people but he chose their blood
onto a skull of sorts and what he
basically ends up getting is this work
called
William hand of course the man that we
know will eventually become black hands
become basically a representative of
necron the entity of the Black Lantern
Corps so again this is really just kind
of Geoff Johns throwing in the OL pepper
and these little tidbits these little
things here and there they give us an
idea of how dangerous things can be now
of course with Hal Jordan flying for
fares air but once he's actually in the
air once he's taken off as a pilot for
him all's right with the world the
problem is that this supplement of all
being right with the world comes to an
end quick fast and in a hurry and the
reason why is because Sinestro shows up
in his path and sinestro's response is
what are you doing now I'm gonna be
honest with you guys throughout fort
Robb probably atmanam gods guys know I
love extra he is amazing
I love Sinestro as a bad guy like even
when he's just a Green Lantern he's just
a jerk but it is hilarious the way he
conducts himself now at this point in
his path of being a Green Lantern
Sinestro is order in the extreme I mean
he's he's regimented he's structured we
can tell that by his hair and by how
well manicured his mustache is he is a
man of order but he also resists
everything that Hal Jordan stands
against and that's why the two bump
heads almost immediately when Sinestro
shows up Howard begins you know asking
all these questions or who are you why
are you here
why did you basically destroy a twenty
million dollar jet so that shows
responses do not question a superior
officer
do not question someone who's more
powerful than you well how drawer dn't
immediately say won't nope now I know
you're not gonna be a friend of mine
because I challenge superior I got a
challenge Authority all the time that's
exactly what I do and of course the two
of them kind of butt heads a little bit
but what this is is Jeff John's showing
up and pointing out all the flaws of
house work and that's why I love
sinestro because with sinestro being
here is one of these things where he's
sinestro's really good at what he does
and he'll make Hal Jordan even better
the problem is Sinestro is a jerk about
the way that he does it but it's one of
these cool things to kind of sidetrack
for saying I know what does it really
make any sense here but bear with me for
a second for years and years and years I
played H play Call of Duty all the time
and I got a new to you but I watched
different youtubers there were people
out there like the mark of Jay like if
you pay attention to what he says he'll
make you better as a player that's
basically kind of what's happening here
with regards to just sinestro that was a
best example I could think about what
kind of comes out of nowhere but that's
the best example I could fake up
Sinestro is is just he's just a jerk for
all intensive purposes but if you listen
to what he says he will make Hal Jordan
a better person you'll make up a better
Green Lantern and that's exactly what
isn't happening more ironically than
that Hal Jordan is getting a lesson here
from Sinestro that most Green Lantern's
could only ever dream of having like
Sinestro would never come down and train
new Green Lantern's he would never play
the role of Kilowog but to get a
one-on-one lesson with Sinestro the
greatest Green Lantern in existence how
drawn is getting somebody that almost
nobody ever gets and this is what he
tells me says look man your your
constructs are a reflection of your
willpower your willpower has to be
focused your willpower has to be trained
fear will crack your willpower anger
will crack your willpower your willpower
has to be pure when when you achieve
that goal will you make your willpower
as pure as it needs to be nothing is
beyond your ability to perform and this
is what he does he basically recreates
he brings the plane back together
of Hal Jordan and that's what's so cool
is because what Sinestro says is you
need more training I'm here because a
friend of mine was killed because you
know avid sir was killed because he's
being chased by spiah by Atrocitus or at
least it's believed to be that case if
you're the Green Lantern of this sector
you need more training you need to be
taught how to be an effective Green
Lantern and so what isn't happening is
of course the two of them kind of part
ways they kind of end up you know
splitting off but what is also happening
here is of course when Hal Jordan gets
back to Ferris air they're immediately
set upon it by Hector Hammond now of
course again this is why I say Hector
Hammond is kind of elevated here you
know celebrity is telekinesis but it's
kind of removed his humanity but the
cool thing about this is that when it
comes to Hal Jordan when it comes to
really anybody in particular physical
punches physical assaults are nothing in
comparison to somebody who would be able
to assault them
the reason why is because our thoughts
are the one place that we could go where
we could be private we can be alone
nobody can know what we're thinking they
could speculate they can guess and be
right but they'll never know with any
absolute certainty it's our one safe
haven it's the last fig leaf and because
of this you know it is basically Hal
Jordan and Carol Ferris being violated
in the most extreme way because their
inner thoughts their inner desires their
lust their fears that things are they
hate the most the regrets they have all
of those are just items they're baubles
in the hand of Hector Hammond just
scrolling through them just perusing
through them and they've never felt a
sense of helplessness quite like this
now the other thing to keep in mind is
that Hector Hammond is very much
infatuated very much lustful after care
affairs I wouldn't call it in love love
is somebody organic love is something
true it takes time to develop Hector
Hammond is just lustful he just wants to
get Carol Ferris between the sheets
that's really all he wants to do here
but Hal Jordan of course donning his
ring this is when he begins to learn
that his willpower just doesn't seem to
be there that his willpower just doesn't
seem to be capable that for whatever
reason he's not able to tap into it the
way that he needs to now of course we'll
learn that this is a reflection of how
Jordans own self now this is a
reflection of how Jordans own lack of
belief in himself he doesn't feel like
as willpower is there because it isn't
there because it's just not where it
needs to be now of course Sinestro jumps
in and basically saves Hal Jordan by way
of just you know more or less shutting
off the air supply of Hector Hammond but
again this is Sinestro saying you need
more training you need to be taught
better and that's what he does
so that's your basic retakes Hal Jordan
under his ring as they go through all
these different investigations they go
to this huge journey to try to find you
know what find out what happened - what
happened to a band sort you know what it
is that that happening with Atrocitus
and and so on and so forth now the funny
thing about this too is that Hal Jordan
directly asked Sinestro about why it is
that you know Green Lancers are weak to
the color yellow because keep in mind
this is before anybody knew that the
parallax entity was confined inside the
central battery and so for all they knew
it was just a weakness to the color
yellow it was just the yellow impurity
they didn't know that that parallax
inside of the central battery was
basically seating weakness into the
Green Lantern's themselves now of course
destro says we don't know and that's not
for you to ask it's not your job to ask
the question of why it is that you know
the yellow impurity is there but even if
he goes as far as to say I've been -
I've been attempting to seek out the
truth for why that's the case
been attempting to try to find out why
it is better there's a yellow impurity
now we know this is basically Jeff Jones
kind of saying this is how it is best
sinestro eventually becomes the
harbinger the face of parallax becomes
the the head of the Sinestro Corps this
is Jeff Johnson this is how these things
begin to sort of grow and evolve and so
on but what is up happening is Hal
Jordan takes an ester arch where it is
that a band saw was buried and this is
when Hal Jordan begins to learn the
relationship between Sinestro and a band
saw in the sense of a band sewer with
Sinestro's mentor they were extremely
close friends I would go as far as to
say that a Basu is probably the one
person that Sinestro actually trusted
but of course with Sinestro being in
such close proximity to Hal Jordan what
it does is it triggers the message
confined inside the ring of a band sword
and what is up happening is a band saw
basically begins to go through and tells
Sinestro everything he knows the
prophecy of the blockless blackest night
the five inversions everything that's
been going on the idea that there will
be a multitude there'll be like five
other Lantern Corps is that what we
don't we'll crop up these other Lantern
cores will basically all go to war
against one another the red the blue the
indigo somewhat and so forth they'll all
go to war against one another and it'll
lead to the end of all emotion and
everything will come crashing down he
spills out the beans on Atrocitus the
five inversions these are people that
basically came out of the massacre a
sector 666 the Manhunters the
predecessors to the Green Lantern's
basically had a flaw in their
programming we'll find out what that
flaw is and what happened that set them
on that path but there'll be a flaw in
the Manhunters program they'll lay waste
to sector 666 the survivors will come
together with an empire of Tears and
they will eventually form themselves
into an enemy of the Green Lantern Corps
this is constantly what's what's
happening here now at this point we
switch back over to William hand with
regards to his whole family now the
reason why I kind of held off on this
William hand thing for a second is
because I wanted to actually wait until
we got into the such of the story that
delved into William hand
but essentially William hand is member
of a family that deals with funerals his
life is surrounded by death but
something else that I hope you also
notice here is that the black lantern
symbol is William hands family crust
it's their family symbol and that's cool
because what this means is that it's not
as though these symbols are kind of you
know pre or game you know there's
symbols are just created they're a
reflection of the different quarters
themselves black hand is a man unto
himself he can resurrect you know we'll
see the whole resurrection
with regards blackest night but in terms
of like Han he's basically a lantern for
unto himself as kind of how it initially
starts up his obsession with death
initially leads him to encountering
Atrocitus and Atrocitus begins to talk
about you know your uh your a doorway
into the darkness you're a person is
going to blur to bring about the
blackest night now of course we'll find
out really how this blackest night our
prophecy stance once we get to Sinestro
Corps war but this is still pretty cool
because but what this basically says is
that it's not enough that they were
going to be lanterns that are basically
going to wage war against one another
and they're all going to die there's a
next step after this there's the rise of
the black lantern so the rise of death
of destruction of darkness of eternal
death you know to to the universe itself
you know is this this really foreboding
scenario but of course with the arrival
of Sinestro and the arrival of Hal
Jordan the cool thing is that house 1
basically gets a crash course in how to
use his ring with regards to the the
fight against Atrocitus is not some
training scenario and that's what
Sinestro says you're not in training my
friend you're not in bootcamp you're in
the real world either you can harness
your will power and you could succeed or
you will fail but we also get these
crash course lessons that that Hal
Jordan gives in terms of like pocket
dimensions storing his power battery in
some location that will basically keep
it safe keep it from being destroyed
again it's all these little small tidbit
that go towards Hal Jordan becoming a
better Green Lantern now facing off
against Atrocitus because of the fact
that that house worden is so new in his
mind he can create constructs to a
degree but they're still not fleshed out
they're still not really where they need
to be they're still not really that
capable Atrocitus can still punch
through them but all this begins to
change when Atrocitus says I know your
rage I know your anger I know that you
are weak I know that you do not have the
ability to be somebody of any real
measured of course he's saying all this
to us Sinestro in the process of getting
ready to kill Sinestro Hal Jordan comes
to his aid and when he does that he
forces a construct to take out a tractor
now utter noble circumstances this would
be entirely irrelevant but the tractor
is yellow the construct should have had
no impact on the track of the constructs
should have broken apart on the tractor
the construction of fall apart before it
reached the tractor because of the
yellow impurity
now the reason why this matters is
because this is where Sinestro really
begins to learn what's going on this is
where how Jordan himself begins to
realize what's going on with the yellow
impurity the yellow impurity is not an
intrinsic thing the yellow impurity is
not something that's just in
to Green Lanterns it's not just a
natural part of the Green Lantern power
the yellow impurity is artificial it's
an external factor it's an external
source if it can be overcome that means
that it's not part of the Green Lantern
landscape someone put it there and so
what this does is this really kind of
bolsters a curiosity of Sinestro anymore
now he doesn't really say anything - Hal
Jordan how does one kind of makes a
comment about hey did you see that I use
I use the the ring against yellow
Sinestro kind of takes away the way that
Geoff Johns gives it to us it's almost
like Sinestro takes this as an affront
and assumes that hazard was able to do
something bet Sinestro was never able to
do and so it kind of comes across as a
situation like you know Sinestro feels
like he feels challenged by Hal Jordan
he feels like Hal Jordan has the
potential to become better than he is
and that's true in a lot of ways but
more so than that this is Sinestro
learning the yellow impurity is
artificial there's something and the
central power battery that makes Green
Lantern's weak - the color yellow how
Jordan was able to temporarily over you
know overcome it and so again this
really kind of bolsters a curiosity of
Sinestro with regards to to everything
that's everything else that's going on
but again Sinestro saying your ring your
willpower serves the purpose of forcing
you to face your fears if you cannot
face your fears you will never be an
adequate Green Lantern and so because of
this we basically have kind of you know
how Jordan flying off on his own
how do wouldn't you know trying to avoid
Sinestro but it is anger and in his
wrath he races off to Carol Ferris he
races off to her family home confronts
her and says I want to speak to your
father I want to speak to Carl Ferris
breaks into Carl Faris's room only to
find that Carl Ferris is bedridden that
he's sick he's in no condition to run
the company and this is when we learned
the truth of what was going on the death
of Hal Jordans father was not done by a
man who was just trying to cut corners
for the for the purpose of saving a buck
you know Carl Ferris was trying to keep
his business afloat but the death of Hal
Jordans father crushed Carl Ferris you
know it ate him alive and it ate him to
the point where he basically just kind
of began to lose the will to live and so
Carol Ferris has basically been making
up a series of excuses well my father's
not playing golf my father's doing this
he's doing that he'd love to be here you
know and while she put off the air of
the fact that her father basically was
too good to be there with the rest of
the grunts so to speak one ends up
happening here as house wouldn't learns
the truth Bo that Carol sees herself as
a spoiled little girl she always saw
herself as a spoiled little girl but
when the time came for her to step up
and to run the family business she was
able to
do that and this is what Hal Jordans
loyalties began to shift and truth Hal
Jordan was flying for fairs air because
he wanted you know to just be able to
fly again but Hal Jordan also now feels
a kinship to Carroll fairs and the
reason why is because he basically comes
to the realization that she's alone
it's just her there's no one else it's
just Carol Farris much like Hal Jordan
he's got nobody else his brother Jim is
you know somewhat a part of his life to
a degree his brother Jack hates him his
father's dead his mother's dead Hal
Jordan feels very isolated very alone in
the world and in this kind of a
situation what it does is it allows two
people to find solace in one another it
allows Carol Ferris and Hal Jordan to
come together in a relationship now what
this also does is it forces Hal Jordan
to reconcile it forces him to look into
himself and it basically let the memory
of his father go and that's what's so
beautiful about this is because this
whole thing this whole story is simply
just Hal Jordan not being able to come
to grips with the fact that everyone
passes that everyone dies sometimes we
die in honourable ways sometimes there's
no honor to it but everybody passes this
struggle of Hal Jordans life though the
failures that he'd experienced his
recklessness
you know his inability to tap into the
full might of his willpower all of that
extended from the fact that he could not
let his father go but he finally does he
finally comes to grips with it he
finally comes to terms with it and this
is the real lesson of Sinestro and this
is this is the moment this is this is
the moment in this story where I was
like this is what I now begin to love
Sinestro this is why Sinestro is now my
favorite milk there's this great
exchange between the two that's one of
the coolest exchanges ever there's a
great exchange what Sinestro says is you
have now learned the power of the Green
Lantern ring the Green Lantern ring is
it gives you the will to do the things
that you need to do whatever those
things may be the the Green Lantern ring
will give you the willpower to let your
father go the Green Lantern ring will
give you the willpower to live you know
and this is what Hal Jordan says look I
understand you're right and Sinestro's
responses I know I know I know I was
right I love that he doesn't do it like
a reasonable human being he was like
well I'm glad you're beginning to
understand the lessons of a Green
Lantern he's just like yeah I know I was
right like what a dick that's why I love
him so much he's my favorite guy but uh
but nonetheless you know it's it's it's
it's cool you know this is also Sinestro
kind of teaching
you know Howard about you know that the
dangers of anger and and so on and so
forth but again it's it's creating a
measure of respect between the two you
know it's is Sinestro basically saying
that when it comes to things like like
regret when it comes to things like loss
things like guilt Green Lantern's always
struggle with that and the reason why is
because Green Lantern's are always the
first ones into the conflict Green
Lanterns end up losing friends Green
Lanterns end up sometimes wishing they'd
never made friends in the first place
because they end up losing them in
battle you know but this is what sesor
says it's always that's that's the
eternal struggle that's the eternal
conflict that you go against is the idea
that you're constantly facing off
against you know forces that would seek
to strip you of your power fear anger
regret remorse those are things that
will constantly seek to strip you of
your abilities of your willpower you
have to remain ever-vigilant
you can't give up who you are but you
constantly have to stay on the defensive
to make sure that your connection with
willpower never goes away now of course
as a tale into this discussion they're
really just kind of like whisked away -
they're really kind of whisked away to
the guardians of the universe and this
is really the first time that Hal Jordan
is actually meeting them and the funny
thing about this is it how's your Dhin
begins to show the Guardians what he is
about it's the best way that I can
explain it um the funny thing is is the
guardians you know talk about the new
Green Lantern of sector you know - eight
one four how Jordans like well you know
he's like my name is Hal Jordan and the
responses they know that they know who
you are Hal Jordan they're well aware of
who you are now at this point this is
when Sinestro basically says hey look
you know there was a lot going on Aven
Seward basically died there so on and so
forth a prophecy of the blackest night
and all that kind of good stuff but
again what is up happening is the
Guardians basically set down the rules
or at least they explain the rules al
Jordan that no Green Lantern's are
allowed to team up with whatever they
have to patrol their own sector you know
there are no Green Lantern's a team up
you know Hal Jordan has his sector two
eight one four
Sinestro has his sector one four one
seven they're not allowed to cross over
into each other sectors the only time
that is permitted is when the Guardians
say it's permitted but they can't go off
and do it on their own now of course
house run ask the question why you know
and because well the Guardian well
because working together
I'm sorry working out working
independently makes you stronger you
know and and then the his question is
why you know into the Guardians like we
just live for a billion years don't
question us we know what we're talking
about
yeah and that's that's what's kind of
interesting here is because you know
Geoff Johns is said in the seeds of
saying that
the Guardians will not give the green
lanterns all the guesses they want you
know some of this is because of the fact
that the Guardians themselves just want
to maintain information to themselves
sometimes it's because of the fact that
the Guardians just do not want to see
the truth of the situation
we'll find that out once we get to the
Sinestro Corps war and you have ganthet
and you have Sayed who are like the to
hold out saying this is going to happen
the privacy of the blackest night is
going to happen but none of the other
Guardians want to listen so again you
know it's really kind of cool because
despite their vaunted appeal lack of
emotions despite their wisdom and how
long about how long they've been around
the guardians are very very much human
in terms of how they conduct himself
their mysticism their cloak-and-dagger
attitude you know everything's very
black and white some of you know so on
and so forth but at this point because
of the fact that the house orden has
basically just been popping off at the
mouth the guardians of the universe are
like you're facing expulsion dude like
we're we're gonna kick you out if you
keep running if you keep you know
talking about who you is well you know
them at that point Sinestro what kind of
charms it says look if you kick out how
to earn you kick out me now this is not
really Sinestro putting his faith in Hal
Jordan it is to a degree but it's really
more of Sinestro
looking at the legacy of a band sewer
you know Aven sort personally said look
Hal Jordan like met him met Hal Jordan
said you are my replacement now it's
really just kind of carrying on what it
is that that Abbas were had going you
know in terms of passing as legacy on
but I think there is also so you know
some measure of trust here between
Sinestro and Hal Jordan at the very
least Sinestro probably respect Hal
Jordan more so that he respects anybody
else or at least as close as Sinestro
can get to respecting a person but at
this point because of the fact that the
the guardians we are not going to give
up their greatest Green Lantern instead
they kind of offer a compromise what
they say is Hal Jordan will be your
direct pupil he will learn directly from
you he will be your responsibility if he
fails then that's your failure and again
you know of course Sinestro angels kind
of taking this on but this is the road
that house were and follows to making
him such a great Green Lantern but again
this really all kind of begins to sort
of wind down he gets to come to an end
with regards to you know Sinestro taking
the body of Atrocitus or at least you
know in taking him back to to its ball
to his really his own home and keep him
prisoner there which we'll find out you
know in this part of the whole Sinestro
Corps war exactly what it was that
happened in this scenario but withheld
Ewan returning back home and you know
him being with with Carol Farris the two
of them are close but as far as she says
look you know it's it's it's miss Ferris
you know it's not Carol you know it's
maintaining this the sort
this propriety between the two of them
so while they're not necessarily
romantic in the traditional sense there
is always going to be this sort of
give-and-take there's going to be this
tug back and forth between the two of
them always looking at the idea that
they're basically going to you know
possibly get together at some point
along the line but again the road is
constantly being set the road is
constantly being paid for example with
Sinestro you know setting Atrocitus back
to you back to his Maul back to his home
planet
what Atrocitus says is we've seen the
future we know what fate awaits you
we know that cooter will descend into
absolute civil unrest and riots we know
that it will descend in absolute madness
and you will do the only thing you know
how to do you will force order onto your
home people and when that happens you
are going to become effectively an evil
Green Lantern you're going to fall from
the path of the Green Lantern and you're
going to become a bad guy and the
Guardians will turn against you but
again it's just kind of this cool
situation because ultimately the way the
story kind of winds down Hal Jordan you
know visits with his brother Jim and how
Droid basically says hey look it's time
that I be honest with you it's time that
I be a good brother for you it's time
that I finally you don't trust you I
finally opened up to you and he
basically says I'm the Green Lantern you
know of course dawn says ring put on a
suit or at least I manifested suit and
then gives two gifts to Jim the flight
journal of Hal Jordan I think that
contains everything this entire origin
story as it exists so far but yeah I
really love this I mean I really love
this this origin story I think is a lot
more complex than a lot of the stories
that we're gonna see with regards to
what goes on and Geoff Johns run of
Green Lantern the cool thing is we get
these little tidbits here and there you
know all right guys so we are officially
in it now I mean we're starting Geoff
Johns Green Lantern the cool thing about
Geoff Johns Green Lantern though is it's
really just a fresh starting off point I
mean we're gonna start from the
beginning I mean every Sunday will be
Geoff Johns Green Lantern until we
finish it so we're gonna be going on
really all the way up until the start of
DC rebirth to be quite frank because DC
rebirth power on the Green Lantern Corps
just picks up where Geoff Johns had
largely left off but um where I think
actually was talking about prevent bidi
I think at the tail end of new 52 but
regardless the fact remains here Geoff
Johns Green Lantern is kind of an
overarching term like you'll see this a
lot if you saw reddit you saw reading
order some like that people all set
Geoff Johns Green Lantern it's not
really just Jeff Joss sorry Geoff Johns
wrote the Maine Green Lantern title but
there's also Green Lantern Corps and
what this does is it tells the same
story from two different sides Green
Lantern focuses on Hal Jordan Green
Lantern Corps focuses on ever
body else now we'll see like John
Stewart will see Guy Gardner crossover
into really into Hal Jordan stories but
on the whole Green Lantern core will
focus on like the lost lanterns the ones
that thought that everybody believed
were dead
you know when Hal Jordan became parallax
supposedly killed everyone as well as
Guy Gardner a Kyle Rayner to a degree
Jon Stewart a lot of spacefaring
adventures different things like that
they'll come to a head when we get to
like the crossover so Sinestro Corps war
blackest night brightest day Revenge of
the Green Lantern's of it things like
that but for right now this is really
just kind of starting off with Geoff
Johns Green Lantern now the cool thing
is remember this is really just kind of
Hal Jordan after he came back after
being parallax now a bit of a refresher
here for those of us who are the Leos
were familiar with green lantern bear
with me for a second because I think
we're not beginning a lot of people who
were kind of new to this with DC trying
to find a way to reinvigorate Hal Jordan
or reinvigorate the Green Lantern mythos
they basically got rid of Hal Jordan and
they replaced him with Kyle Rayner now
of course this came out of the death of
Superman because the death of Superman
was as good of a point as any as to
basically you know to reboot the entire
Green Lantern mythos so to reinvigorate
him so what do you see did is they had
House Irwin come back from space only to
find out the cyborg superman and a
villain named mongol had destroyed KO
city and then in return Hal Jordan made
more or less lost his mind he use his
ring for selfish reasons to basically
recreate the city that kind of a thing
and what it did is it set in motion the
Guardians chastising him for it Hal
Jordan lost his mind he went crazy he
killed virtually all the Green Lantern's
he killed all the guardians of the
universe except for ganthet ganthet who
finally managed to make his way people
kept giving me a hard time about like
putting an Ellen there it doesn't really
matter too much to me but people were
giving me a hard time about it I was
like whatever I'll try to pronounce it
as best I can but the fact remains here
that that Hal Jordan basically became
parallax he adopted the name of parallax
now what rebirth it up sorry what uh
what green legend rebirth did is it came
back in a said none and enough parallax
was not a name that Hal Jordan adopted
parallax is an actual entity now how
that influenced Hal Jordans life will
actually find out over the course of
this story but the cool thing here is
that this really kind of gives us a bit
of a refresher because you got to
remember you know Green Lantern rebirth
was one thing it's another to actually
start a new volume and the good thing
about what geoff johns does is he gives
us a lot of stuff but he does it in a
way that makes sense and is easily
digestible as well as treating every
single story every single beginning of a
news story or
as though somebody's picking it up for
the very first time and so again it's
easily accessible it's just one of those
things where despite its ease of access
it's better when it's read as a whole
and so again what this does is kind of
jump back to the early days of Hal
Jordan basically being you know being
offered the Green Lantern ray by a dance
or of course we know that Hal Jordan
accepts the offer and again it just kind
of picks up with him as part of a ferris
heir now of course Ferris air has
basically groaned you know since the
last video we did where we talked about
Hal Jordans secret origin where he was
basically the last man standing working
alongside Carol Ferris to try to keep
Ferris air intact but what this also
does is it brings in a person by the
name of cowgirl now again the cool thing
about this is that Hal Jordan really
kind of reminds us that he never really
uses his ring unless he absolutely has
to instead you know he prefers to fly
without his ring and kind of you know
keeps the thrill of exhilaration it
keeps things going a total of him
maintaining his interest at the same
time there's basically a craft of sorts
that's been detected by Hal Jordan is
currently you know orbiting the planet
Earth when they get there and they
investigate it they end up finding out
that this craft you know doesn't really
seem to have any recognizable features
which is to say it's not earth made what
this does is it coincides with the
arrival of what appears to be a robot
actually a Manhunter now of course the
Manhunters appearance here just comes
with eradicating virtually everybody
that it comes across but this Manhunter
looks totally different from the ones
we've seen before because the Manhunters
as we know there are usually cloaked in
red they have a very distinctive look in
terms of how they appear this is this
seems to be a new generation now at this
point we kind of jump into like the
aftermath of what's going on with
regards to how Jordan returned keep in
mind Coast City had been totally
obliterated and the result is that Coast
City has actually been dubbed ghost City
and the reason why is because there's
hardly anybody there not only that again
we pick up with Hal Jordans younger
brother Jim now of course we saw with
regards to secret origin that Hal Jordan
was trying to reconnect with his younger
brother he was trying to reconnect with
him trying to help him understand where
he was coming from everything that was
going on with the return of Hal Jordan
following you know of course is presumed
death while he was parallax originally
becoming the spectre he's basically
trying to reconnect with his younger
brother but what Jim says is that he's
not coming back that he has no intention
of coming back to Coast City almost no
one does and that's the issue a lot of
money's being thrown behind the
redevelopment of Coast City a lot of
money's being thrown behind basically
restoring it to the
way that it used to be the problem is
that everybody's terrified of living
there because either they've lost
friends and family where they were there
and it's just too hard to go back
because people are afraid it'll be
destroyed again because people just
don't see a reason to go there because
there aren't very many thriving
businesses there's one of these
circumstances where no one really seems
to seems to have a reason to be there
except for those who have basically
lived there their whole lives and just
refused to leave or people who have
moved in because property's cheap and
different things like that but again in
the middle of this conversation between
Hal Jordan and his brother Jim we're
basically met with the introduction of
cowgirl now cowgirl is actually a pretty
cool care to Rivet us or call us on in
the airforce I was never in the Air
Force I've only known a couple people
who have but as far as I'm aware in the
Air Force I guess they have call signs
I'm not 100% sure about that but in the
in this instance this girl's call sign
is cowgirl now cowgirl and does not seem
like she would be relevant or really
important to see like she'd be a
throwaway character she'll actually be
huge when we get to the to the star
sapphire and that'll that'll be really
really awesome but again what we end up
finding out here is that with this
particular plane is flying it's
basically powered by what appears to be
Manhunter technology and this is when we
learned that you know with this vessel
that it basically crash-landed on earth
you know with the actions of the US
government going in investigating so on
and so forth throughout the history of
house wouldn't be in the green lantern
the government it basically stumbled
upon Manhunter tech and that's what
they're doing they're basically using it
and they're adopting it to their own
ends they're basically trying to figure
out a way to replicate Manhunter
technology and use it continually now
again at this point we switch over to a
guy named general stone now again I know
I'm throwing a lot at you guys but this
is really a lot of world-building by
Geoff Johns that's really what he's
doing here the first couple trades the
first couple of volumes you know with
regards to you know like like this this
particular story Green Lantern OFIR
Green Lantern Corps recharge it's a
refresher it's basically just kind of
throwing a lot of stuff at us really
really fast so that we could kind of
build on it later on now of course again
this will all make sense as we go
through it'll all just kind of come
together and it'll create a very very
tight-knit and cohesive story so just
bear with me on this one this little
part but general stone is actually
really important to the history of Hal
Jordan reason why is because again
general stone is a reason why Hal Jordan
was booted from the Air Force Hal Jordan
was basically trying to find a way to
get out of the Air Force so he could go
see his dying mother because his dying
mother's one request was that as long as
Hal Jordans of the Air Force he cannot
come see her he punched general stone
and of course general stone had him
kicked out now again the cool thing
about this is that with the two of them
talking with one another general stone
does not know that Hal Jordan is the
Green Lantern is said it's just hey
Green Lantern thanks for saving our
pilot thanks for saving our ship that
kind of thing but it's basically a
reintroduction of familiar faces now
general stones role will be bolstered
you know as we go through the Green
Lantern stories and so on and so forth
but again you know we're really just
kind of transition to to this Manhunter
as is being carried by convoy and
basically seems to go awry of course
with with Jon Stewart the Green Lantern
investigating everything that's going on
he's working in tandem with with with
Hal Jordan and of course Jon Stewart
someone is kind of doing a lot of a lot
of the legwork now the reason why this
is the case oh this creates a little bit
of a a little bit of contention you know
among some fans of the Green Lantern
mythos the reason why is because in
truth Jon Stewart is like the number two
guy Gardner the number three if you had
to go through and rake them a truth
there are fans out there who love Jon
Stewart and don't like anybody else
there are fans who like Guy Gardner and
they don't like anybody else Kyle Rayner
Hal Jordan is all the same thing but Hal
Jordan was the first of the Green
Lantern's on earth and so he really kind
of holds a level of superiority among
all the other Green Lantern's the kicker
to this so the difference here is that
Jon Stewart brings his own area of
expertise and that's really why it is
that Hal Jordan is defecting to Jon
Stewart here because Jon Stewart was an
architect job stewart was in the
military
Jon Stewart has a lot of experience
dealing with different scenarios that
have to you know they coincide with
structural weaknesses determining what
it is that caused something to fail if
Hal Jordan showed up here he could
probably pull it off but not as well as
Jon Stewart and that's the great thing
about Jeff Jon's work here is because
Geoff Johns
looks at each of the individual Green
Lantern's really each of them individual
members of the entire Lantern mythos and
says what are their strengths and
weaknesses we'll put them in situations
where their strengths are highlighted
we'll take them out of situations where
their weaknesses are highlighted and
we'll put somebody else in their place
and so what it does is create a really
really cool and rich method of
storytelling where we basically get a
lot of the characters at the height of
their abilities now of course a lot of
this will be turned upside down with
Sinestro Corps war especially given the
limitations of the Green Lantern ring
versus the lack of limitations with the
Sinestro Corps ring but the fact remains
here that with Hal Jordan you know going
back to visit his brother you know going
back to speak with Jim after having
previously taken off
Jim kind of reiterates this point that
Jim his wife is kids they're not
coming back to coast city but for Hal
Jordan it's like look people are trying
to build here the only way anything is
gonna grow is if people start coming
back somebody has to take that first
step and Jim's responses then go find
somebody else and again it's really kind
of cool here because what it shows us is
that instead of making this isolated
instead of treating things as though the
destruction of Coast City happened but
nobody really cares about the impact it
tells us the impact lives on that people
are terrified of living there nobody
wants to be the one who gets blown up on
coast city now again at this point it
really kind of transitions back over to
back over to Hal Jordan continuing on
his journey you know going through and
investigating a lot of this information
and so on and so forth with regards to
you know the Manhunter and you know that
kind of information but ultimately with
the Manhunter having been successfully
transported to a military base with no
one being aware that they're basically
toting a Manhunter Hal Jordans ring
kicks into play
you know recognizes a Manhunter is
currently in the vicinity and the result
is that of course he activates and the
two of them kind of began you know
battling with one another you know going
towards what now again the cool thing is
that with geoff johns writing this story
what he does is basically give the
reader you know us as the reader a
refresher on who the Manhunter
Manhunters are and he does this
organically he doesn't by way of you
know when Hal Jordan tells us his ring
what the heck's going on the ring goes
through a quick explanation of the
Manhunters which we can go ahead and do
that here so with regards to people who
are who are new to the whole mythos the
Manhunters were really like up until the
most recent red comm with regards to the
origin of all through the Manhunters are
basically the predecessors to the green
lantern so the reason why is because of
the fact that the Guardians have
basically given up their emotion and the
line of logic from the guardians of the
universe was that individuals who have
emotion who were tied into their
emotions can be easily manipulated they
could succumb to wrath they can succumb
to happiness to love to anger so on and
so forth what we need are people who
will basically carry out their mission
no questions asked the Manhunters were
designed to be that way the issue is
that a programming glitch took place at
the Manhunters where they started going
on a violent crusade what it basically
said the only way to keep you and to
keep the universe in order is to
eliminate all life people you know races
different organisms cannot succumb to
anger if they don't exist they can't go
to war if there's nothing for them to go
to war over because they're all dead the
problem with this is that of course the
lanters were created in order to respond
to the idea that the Manhunters were too
extreme and the Green Lantern's really
just kind of grew
and expanded ever since but the
Manhunters have cropped up from time to
time and this is one of those instances
where the question is okay how did this
man hunter get here well we're kind of
left to believe this man hunter got here
at some point in the distant past you
know at some point along the line and it
was just now discovered in fact that's
the case it's actually going to be made
the kicker is that in the middle of the
conflict between Hal Jordan and this man
hunter the newer version of the man
hunter that's cooked in blue shows up
now of course how Jordan looks at it as
a person that you know as a being that
looks human and thinks it is some kind
of backup whether it's a super-powered
being that he's never seen before or
something along those lines but of
course this sent a second man hunter
turns against Hal Jordan and attacks
them within the question that Hal Jordan
has is where where did this man hunter
come from because it looks brand-new
it looks newly created if the man hunter
is newly created who's making it who
armed who's making these new generations
of man hunters the other half of this
being because this new man hunter
basically looks at the more damaged
version it says you're older you're
archaic you're not new like I am so
that's where geoff johns really gets to
kind of set the seeds plant the seeds of
what's going on now a lot of this will
be answered in Green Lantern Corps but
with regards to what's going on at the
moment this is an example of what Geoff
Johns does where he basically engineers
a situation where questions are kind of
being asked where people are trying to
figure out what's going on
at the same time something else that we
also learn here is that with this newest
iteration of the Manhunters they're not
like previous versions instead this
newest version has the ability to absorb
green lantern energy and so what it does
is it makes the Manhunters a lot more
dangerous than they were before because
instead of a man instead of a green
lantern having to run up on a Manhunter
and deal with their enhanced strength
and so on and so forth now the
Manhunters will absorb green energy from
Green Lantern's and so again it creates
kind of a weird situation because Hal
Jordan is trying to figure out what's
going on is trying to figure out where
things are going now of course at this
point he goes and and begins to kind of
question general stone and it's kind of
cool because you don't own is really
stonewalling him here I mean not gonna
do a play on words but he's like hey
look man a lot of this is confidential
information you know it's it's top
secret we can't really tell you what
we're doing we can't tell you about this
tech we can't give you any of that stuff
you know and in the end you know house
was like look I need information and he
actually ends up punching general stone
now of course that's when general stone
basically figures out who had who green
lantern is he knows right off the bat
the Green Lantern is Hal Jordan he
doesn't tell him immediately you know he
just kind of gives them a little bit of
information here cause ruins
says look I need to borrow your jet I've
got to go chase after this manhunt to
remember Kyle Jordan's ring has been
drained of energy quite a bit and so you
know in the pursuit of this of this
Manhunter again it leads to a pretty
crazy chase of course you got
journalists on on one side of the calms
you've got green lantern on the other
but it's really just kind of a back and
forth here I mean it's really more like
an action segment more so than any real
you know genuine information to go on
here now of course because of the fact
that Hal Jordan can't really summon his
lantern at the moment he basically just
uses the head of the of the Manhunter to
basically re-energize his ring but again
the question that he's asking here is
where did this Manhunter come from not
only that one of the Manhunters begins
to basically experience or begins to
show emotion and that's why things are
beginning to look funny - Hal Jordan
because man hunters are inherently
devoid of emotion but we're this man
hunter that he's basically taking out of
the atmosphere and getting ready to you
know leave out in space due to the fact
that its self-destruct mechanism has
been activated in the final moments of
its life the Manhunter says it feels
fear man hunters never feel emotion and
so the question how Jordan has is how
did we get to this place why is this man
hunter feeling emotion this man hunter
should not feel any emotion of any kind
whatsoever and so what he does is you
know Jeff Jones kind of gives us us a
little bit of a teaser we basically kind
of picks up with with Hal Jordan and
says look there is someone out there who
is making these these you know these
robots making these new man hunters
these new man hunters are a little
different they're a little more capable
and so the idea is what or what exactly
are they going to be able to pull off
what exactly are they going to be able
to do now at this point we really kind
of jumped to like this weird little
story that that Geoff Johns gives us but
it's basically him kind of leading into
the prophecy of the blackest night
leading it to the idea that we're
basically gonna come to a war of all the
different Lantern courts now initially
this just kind of picks up with just
some alien out and out in the desert
somewhere and it's actually hit you know
by a vehicle alien so he says you know I
just went out for a cigarette but it's
also kind of cool here because we get
this a little bit of a return of
familiarity with house weren't visiting
the different members of the Green
Lantern Corps now of course he and
Kilowog kind of get into a bit of a beef
they get into a little bit of a battle
with one another but it's really a
friendly one it's not designed to be
violent by any stretch of the
imagination but in the midst of this Hal
Jordan is contacted by Hector Hammond
and Hector Hammond
they're back now again this is Jeff
John's changing things up event adding
these little tidbits of information that
will go towards expanding the mythos now
with regards to this alien that was hit
by car and you know was basically taken
by the US government that what ends up
happening is they basically start going
through its body and realizing that this
alien is basically human but it's been
aged by like 50,000 years or something
silly like that
it's basically what humans will become
at some point along the law and due to
their you know evolutionary process
evolutionary continuation so because of
this Houser when he goes to visit Hector
Hammond since Hector Hammond was the one
that contacted him now again hunter
Hammonds a really really cool villain
he's one of those guys that I find to be
really intriguing just because of the
fact that Hector Hamid can't actually
move anywhere I mean he's got a massive
head and has to be kept on some measure
of a support system in order to keep her
from just kind of nil flopping over but
Hector Hammond is also a guy that
because he can't control his physical
body because he's strictly a telepathic
and telekinetic being that he can't
enjoy the small luxuries of life and
that's the coolest thing about this is
that when geoff johns gives us this
little bit of a story it's basically him
you know kind of showing us what life
would be like without the ability to
taste without the ability to experience
love physical lot of emotion a lot of
different things like that what Hector
Hammond says is I will tell you what's
going on but you have to let me have a
memory you have to let me have an
experience some girl that you are with
some girl whose conversation you paid
attention to you don't let me let me
experience that you know that that
fluttering of love you know those
butterflies in your stomach the hope
that something great will come out of
the night you know let me have that
memory of course Hal Jordan gives it to
him for slight second but then Hector
Hammond tries to overwhelm him now again
this is cool because what it does is it
shows us the experience that Hal Jordan
has with Hector Hammond because Hector
Hammond is a guy who doesn't have normal
abilities because he's not a normal
person
he realized most exclusively on
telepathy the impact of damage done to
his mind is amplified that much more and
so what Hal Jordan does is basically
reach into his brain of course using his
using his lantern technology and
initiate or at least kind of stimulate
the the the pain sector of Hector
Hammond's - so literally he's just kind
of sending his body into an extreme form
of pain of course what Hector Hammond
does is basically spill the beans and
say but there are these beings that
exists out there these weird little
aliens that don't do anything more than
just kind of
messe people they kidnap stuff you know
kidnap individuals they just kind of
experiment on them and see what all they
can pull off and of course you know what
hector says is i'm not the only one now
again this really kind of scenes out in
left-field it really kind of seems out
in the middle of nowhere but all of this
is designed for the purpose of building
up to something bigger again he really
just kind of switch over to KO city you
know to or the the water off the off the
coast of Costa d-- and we had a finding
basically a shark that's been mutated
now this is not king shark alright this
is basically just a normal shark whose
physical design has been manipulated and
been screwed up by these particular
aliens and been jump-started into the
future you know so that is basically
evolved at an extremely rapid rate now
again at this point all this really does
is just show Hal Jordan facing off
against the shark there's really nothing
of any major substance here the only
exception to this is when we switch over
to Palmdale and hillside Park and we
basically end up joining with William
hand now remember the last time we saw
William hand he had basically had he had
lost his hand when the specter had taken
it and so because of this what this does
is it basically kind of gives us this
idea that William hand is kind of this
avatar of death in the sense that if
William hand goes through and touches
things and drains the life energy out of
things then what it does is it begins to
regrow his hand now it's not like he did
touch a tree and the whole thing comes
back it just sort of begins to grow back
and what William hand begins to realize
is that in order for him to regrow his
entire hand he's going to have to
basically absorb the life force of
people so that's literally what he does
he starts traveling around and basically
absorbing the life force out of doctors
out of nurses out of patients that are
currently dying out of virtually every
single person that he comes across and
reconstitutes his physical hand now the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that this is Jeff John sitting
down and laying the groundwork for black
hand being an avatar of Necron the
entity of the Black Lantern Corps and so
what this does is as far as I could tell
is it takes the previous standing of
black hand and it modifies it a bit and
what I mean by that is William Han is a
long-standing villain of the Green
Lantern mythos he originally appeared in
1964 the issue here is that back in the
early days he was just a goofy guy he
was just a goofy little villain he would
spout all these little cliche lines
there was nothing of any real substance
to his character geoff johns coming back
with secret origin changed things up you
know there was a point where by William
and had this device that would absorb
green lantern energy and so what Jeff
Jones is doing is basically saying look
William hand is part of a much bigger
picture you know where the Green
Lantern's are avatars of the willpower
entity in the emotional spectrum black
hand is the avatar of Necron of the
Black Lantern Corps the same way that
the source sapphires are avatars the
same way the Indigo's are avatars and so
on and so forth Sinestro you know an
avatar parallax different things like
that that they basically draw off the
energy of the emotional spectrum now
again this basically picks it with Hal
Jordan discovering who these aliens are
these aliens kind of experimenting on
Hector Hammond Petra Hammond basically
saying they're the ones that made him
the way he was that instead of Hector
Hammond stably just stumbling across the
the ship of a band sort and then turning
around and activating this this meteor
unintentionally that instead the the
aliens had basically engineered this
situation so that the US military would
find the ship of heaven soar and then
turn around an experiment on it
resulting in Hector Hammond becoming who
he is again we had talked about that in
the a secret origin of Hal Jordan but at
this point we basically transitioned
over to William hand encountering Hal
Jordan again now this is where the
tables have turned this is where things
are different then even within the comic
Jeff Johnson talks about this you have
black hand who's basically taunting how
Jordan sank there was a time where I was
just a small-time guy I was a small-time
though now I'm an actual serious foe
now I'm an actual serious threat more so
than that what black hand is basically
saying is Hal Jordan you should be dead
you should not be alive you were
supposed to be dead you were supposed to
be gone somehow you have survived it
shouldn't be that way and so again it's
really this idea of William hands entire
obsession with the idea death coming to
bear now keep in mind
William hands not acting of his own
volition you know his mind had more or
less been kind of messed with than
tampered with
he's been influenced by Necron time and
time again this all really feeds off of
black hands obsession with the concept
of death remember you know William hands
family were basically corners they dealt
with corpses day in and day out
William hands life is a murse in death
and that's exactly what he tells how
Jordan says your whole life is
surrounded by death the death of your
father the death of your mother the
death of the relationships between you
and your brothers your life is nothing
but death and destruction
you yourself have reaped death on a
multitude of different people now again
it's really kind of showing us the fact
that there's somebody out there that
holds such an absolute belief
the value of death but again how's
orange response here that he's not
really afraid of death so much as he
hates death but even then he basically
says without life death is nothing so
again this is Geoff Johns fleshing out
the emotional spectrum this is Geoff
Johns basically telling us on one end
you have white on one end you have black
you've got stuff in between but the
emotional spectrum spreads throughout
all forms of existence life death
willpower love all these different
things are all part of the emotional
spectrum and so again it's really cool
because it's just kind of laying the
early groundwork planting the early
seeds we are by no means in the realm of
seedlings right now we basically just
have seeds in the ground we're nurturing
them and trying to see what we can grow
them into and that's why geoff johns
writing is so good is because instead of
just simply saying and now one day we
had the Black Lanterns instead it's a
slow build it's a slow burn and then it
grows into this giant monstrosity of
just incredible writing that just turned
out to be something absolutely gorgeous
but again what this story does is it
basically kind of ends on the notion
that Hector Hammond has essentially
regained his ability to talk you know
where he's no longer I can find just
kind of being stuck in this this
deteriorated body that he's regained the
ability to talk now how far this will go
is something we don't know but again
these little you know aliens are
basically handed over to the Green
Lantern's the other green other members
of the Green Lantern's you know it for
their own sectors so they can basically
you know be taken back and put on trial
and that kind of thing but again this is
really all just world building stuff the
story itself seems like it has nothing
to do with anything but it has
everything to do with everything it's
gonna be one of these well will actually
reference this later on in future video
so again this is why I wanted to do it
all because you know I don't really want
to leave anything to chance I don't want
to leave anything out even if the story
seems totally irrelevant seems totally
unnecessary we're gonna cover it anyway
and the reason why is because you know
what geoff johns does this is I really
can't harp on this enough what geoff
johns does is he'll write Sinestro Corps
all right here right Sinestro Corps war
and he'll reference one panel from this
entire story but it's important that we
know what's going on that we can all
kind of have this this well-rounded huge
particular understanding of the whole
thing I don't know I'm getting kind of
careless I'm really excited I'm really
really excited to do these stories
all right so the revenge of the Green
Lanterns Prelude it is a maze and gets
super good actually we'll get to see
Batman become a Green Lantern like or at
least what it would look like with him
as a Green Lantern it's only for a
moment but it is free stellar it's
pretty awesome that's one of the things
not really loved about Geoff Johns
writing is this like you have to see
these cool little moments or characters
that you would never see put on Lantern
ring suddenly become a lantern and it is
it looks amazing Batman as a Green
Lantern looks incredibly amazing it's
one of the coolest things where we're
gonna see so initially this picks up
with Hal Jordan on on OA and he's
actually talking to salak now the reason
why this is revenge of the Green
Lantern's preload is because of the fact
that the the main revenge of the Green
Lantern story is gonna deal with the
fallout of the direct fallout of emerald
Twilight now for those of you guys who
were new to the Green Lantern mythos if
I bring up the name parallax you guys
are probably gonna think of parallax is
like the giant yellow entity and that
makes sense because that's what he is
now he's he's the entity he's the you
know the representation of the emotional
spectrum with regards to fear but back
in the 1990s parallax was just a name
that Hal Jordan gave himself and so when
Parrott went when Hal Jordan just sorted
running around operating his parallax uh
he killed basically all the Green
Lantern's you know he really took the
Rings and so on and so forth destroyed
them all like his ring was recreated and
given to Kyle Rayner but uh he was
basically just a bad guy and so what
we've into the Green Lantern's is going
to do is actually going to show us that
not all of those original Green
Lantern's died that some of them lived
but they've simply been held away
they've been kept in stasis by cyborg
superman
ever since they're they're presumed ever
since the events of emerald twilight
took place now of course the reason why
this is significant is because of the
fact that so lock basically sits down
when he'll join us says look man like
the the guardians of the universe is
basically absolved you this they've
welcomed you back into the fall they
said you're no longer a guy who's to be
shunned you're a member of the Green
Lantern Corps who's to be celebrated and
really the greatest of the Green Lantern
Corps but what's the lock says is just
because the the Guardians have forgiven
you doesn't mean everybody else has
basically says you're gonna want to
watch your back because the veterans
know what you did they've heard about
what you did those individuals who are
brand new will hear about what you did
and some individuals may have lost
friends and family some people inherited
the rings of their mothers and fathers
and so because of that they're going to
blame you for the law
the ones that they care about and if
you're not careful it's gonna cost you
your life so again what this does is it
shows us that just because they're green
lantern's doesn't mean there's not
infighting it doesn't mean that there's
not bickering and arguing and that some
individuals just can't get along and
that there aren't grudges being held all
of that stuff still exists and that's
why it's so cool is because Jeff Jones
does not take this standard of well
they're all Green Lanterns and they're
all best friends no he says they're
Green Lantern's but modding don't like
each other and a lot of them would
rather kill other Green Lantern's and
see somebody wear that lantern range so
again it's really kind of a cool idea
here what we do is again because of the
fact that Hal Jordan largely focuses on
events that are on earth we transition
over to Gotham City and the reason why
is because of the fact that Batman
informs Hal Jordan that there's someone
running around called the tattoo man now
of course the cool thing about this is
Geoff Johns draws on the existing Hal
Jordan mythos remember when Green
Lantern rebirth was launched and Hal
Jordan came back in the whole history of
parallax and everything was explained
Geoff Johns it wasn't like a hard reboot
Geoff Johns didn't wipe the slate clean
from the Green Lantern mythos we can
treat it that way
but it isn't that way and truth the
entire history of Hal Jordan remains
intact he was first given the Green
Lantern ring by a bandsaw
he went on to become you know one of the
most capable Green Lantern's he was of
course he really had a Sinestro as his
main villain eventually he became
parallax Kyle Rayner took his place as
the last Green Lantern and then we went
into Green Lantern rebirth back when
when everything was kind of uh kind of
started over again by Geoff Johns but
the reason why I bring that up is
because Hal Jordan makes reference to a
guy who is actually the original
tattooed man what Hal Jordan says is
that the only tattooed man he knows
about is a guy by the name of Abel
Tarrant Mabel Tarrant was a tattooed man
for quite some time and basically had
the ability to make his tattoos take
physical form but the new one is a guy
by the name of Mark Richards now mark
Richards is actually just kind of like
what we get here in the story is really
all we get for his character barring you
know final crisis but prior to that all
we had here was all that we got he was
just a guy he was a former US Marine he
just showed up on the scene one day he
had the ability to turn his tattoos into
physical beings and then those those
tattoos will carry out his own wishes
attack people different things like that
the most recent victim is a guy by the
name of Rosen and this guy was basically
killed and then you know what was
written on his chest was simply the
phrase weakness women and that seems to
be the basis behind the tattooed man is
he literally goes around and kills
people for their sins now the other half
of this is that Batman really kind of
looks down on Hal Jordan now we know the
Batman doesn't like lanterns and all of
this really stems back to Emerald
Twilight well I wouldn't say that Batman
and Hal Jordan were ever the best of
friends I would say that Hal Jordan was
the last person Batman expected to turn
villain to turn into a bad guy and so
that issued a lot of betrayal on behalf
of Batman he's never really liked
lanterns following the events of Emerald
Twilight now he does hold a special
grudge for Hal Jordan and because of
this you know with with Hal Jordan
despite the fact that he showed up he
cast off his identity as parallax he's
no longer the specter it's just how
Jordan the pilot and Green Lantern
Batman still wants to get even of course
he does this by punching the heck out of
him he punches the absolute heck out of
him and that's it no muss no fuss that's
one of the really cool things that's one
of things I like about guys I think I
don't think guys hold grudges for a
lengthy amount of time that was a lesson
I learned in middle school in middle
school two girls would start fighting at
the beginning of the year and they would
fight for the whole year the whole
school year with guys it wasn't like
that guys like yeah man like I don't
like you and then they'd fight anything
they were friends or they just didn't
like each other from then on out but
they wouldn't find everyday you know
they wouldn't take potshots at each
other and stuff like that but the fact
remains here that with their differences
more or less set aside even if only for
the time being what Jeff Jones does is
he actually gives us some really cool
insight into the differences between
Batman and and Hal Jordan what we know
about Batman is Batman is a is a
creature of the night I mean if that's
his thing he hides in the shadows you
know he pops out of cracks in the ground
you know he shows up out of nowhere and
subdues various villains he relies on
fear in order to ensure that those
individuals who would commit a crime
don't commit a crime or at the very
least think twice about it
Hal Jordan on the other hand does not
view himself that way in his mind he
wants to be a beacon for villains he
wants all villains everywhere to see him
and his motivation behind that is when
he says the reason why is because well
he wants the villains to see him instead
of anybody else he wants the villains to
target him instead of targeting
innocent people so again it's actually a
really cool philosophy between the two
of them but this fight with regards to
mark Rogers with regards to the tattooed
man is pretty short-lived but the reason
why this is a prelude for a revenge
of the of the Green Lanterns is because
of the fact that in their conflict what
Mark Richards does is he confirms the
fact that the various tattoos he has on
his body are in relation to the sins
that people have committed murder wrath
greed arrogance different things like
that the sins of man the things that
basically been people towards tendencies
regarding evil as opposed to good and
what he does is he look at it looks at
how Jordan and he says there are so many
sins on you murder betrayal lies deceit
you are a sinful man and is basically
geoff johns harkening to the idea that
there's a lot of history that Hal Jordan
hasn't dealt with and that's true how
she one just kind of showed up on the
scene and said hey I'm back I'm back to
my normal self guys I'm ready to be a
superhero again and that was it that was
really all we got up to this point there
was no indication no inclination that he
had any intention to make up for his
past misdeeds and we'll talk about that
more when we get to revenge of the Green
Lantern's but of course with Batman
being the other half of this equation
Batman joins into the fray and then
subdues Mark Richards pretty quick I
mean it's like it's a two page battle I
mean there's really not much about it
but that was a basis was to basically
take the guy out and call it a day now
the other half of this and the reason
why one of the reasons the ways that we
get to see Green Lantern Batman is when
Hal Jordan sits down with him and says I
want to show you something I want you to
do something and when Batman turns
around he gives them her hands him the
Green Lantern ring and he simply since
put it on put it on and try to use it
now oh really a lot of this is because
of the fact that as Hal Jordans gift to
Batman with regards to the Green Lantern
ring Geoff Johns is kind of explaining
this to us and simply saying the ability
to overcome great fear is fear of the
unknown but fear of your own past it's
fear of the mistakes that you've made
and fear that you may fall right back
down to those mistakes again with
regards to Batman it feeds on the fear
that he has in himself Batman's not
really afraid of villains that man's not
really afraid of bad guys he's not
really afraid of ultra powerful people
like Superman despite the fact that
they're heroes
Batman is afraid of the fact that he
won't honor his parents
Batman is afraid of the fact that he's
going to fail the task that he set for
himself now the way that we know this is
because Hal Jordan says you can't forget
about the things that happened to you
but when you're in that that space in
between the bad experiences that you've
had and your attempt to let them go
that's where the power of the Ring comes
from Batman harnesses it and is able to
harness the power of the Green Lantern
and it is the coolest looking thing ever
it's so awesome you know and in house
written simply says overcome this fear
put that moment behind you put your
childhood fear of Joe Chill put the fear
that you felt when your parents were
shot let that go put that behind you now
Batman's response is I don't want to but
the way that this happens is with him
basically conjuring constructs any
conscious constructs of his parents and
that's what's so cool about this is
because of all the things that he could
have conjured the one thing he wanted to
see was his parents and it's a really
touching moment it's a beautifully done
moment because right now this is not
Bruce wayne/batman it's not the scary
terrifying Bruce Wayne Batman this is
the kid Batman this is eight nine ten
year old Bruce Wayne is what this is
that's why Geoff Johns Green Lantern
Geoff Johns man
if God will write in Green Lantern right
now is what it look like right now it is
an amazing little bit of storytelling
here so again you know Bruce
wayne/batman basically says I don't want
to put this behind me and the motivation
behind this is because of the fact that
if he put his childhood fear behind him
if he put away the fear that he might
not live up to the honor of his parents
if he puts away the fear that after you
know his time as Batman has done that he
just hasn't made Gotham safe didn't
there wouldn't be a reason for him to be
Batman he would basically be forced to
walk away for the mantle and so for this
moment for for right now he simply says
the fear that I have of failing my
parents the fear that I felt as a child
and the anger that I feel now is my
motivation for continuing to be Batman
and I will not rest until Gotham City is
safe and so because of this gift that
Hal Jordan gave to Batman it's basically
kind of a mending of rifts it's the two
of them coming together to a degree and
Batman finally saying thank you you know
I'm glad you're back and so what this
does it just kind of sets the stage I
mean they're not the best of friends
it's not like Green Arrow and Green
Lantern they're not the best of friends
but the various rifts that existed
between the two of them the animosity
that Batman had for Hal Jordan is for
the most part beginning to go away so
from this point going forward we are on
the road to Sinestro Corps war which I'm
really really excited about this is
actually it's a really really great
story but again the way the Geoff Johns
does this is just by building up little
tidbits here and there giving us these
little small things these tiny little
things I just sort of pop up from time
to time when we'll actually see that
take place here in this video at least
the very early days of it all kind of
coming together but the idea here
is that we initially pick up one year
later now with regards to the Green
Lantern mythos it's the Green Lantern
Corps and the Green Lantern one year
later the reason why is because of
course when we covered Infinite Crisis
following the conclusion of that story
DC sat down and said look we already
have our mainstay characters basically
the people who are the core members of
the Justice League what we need is to be
able to get some emphasis to either new
characters or use the popularity of
Infinite Crisis to basically bring in a
bunch of characters that normally
wouldn't get a whole lot of
representation and give them a chance to
be seen and so what basically happened
is DC released a line of stories called
52 and it was literally one story every
week and it went on for a full 52 weeks
a full calendar year and what we
basically got were all these different
stories involving smaller characters and
showing what they were doing in the year
between the conclusion of Infinite
Crisis and the time the major
superheroes basically returned back to
the landscape and so the cool thing is
that with the Green Lantern story and
the Green Lantern core story we
basically join everything a year later
now again a lot of this is really just
kind of how Jordan - sort of talking to
different people as so on and so forth
again it's sort of designed to be an
introductory introductory line of
stories but one of the major emphases
that deaf Jones is putting here is the
fall out of Hal Jordans time as parallax
remember during the events of the death
of Superman cyborg superman and Mongol
had basically destroyed Coast City Hal
Jordan came back from a space mission to
find everything he knew in love
completely obliterated he went insane
with madness and grief declared himself
to be parallax and then just basically
started ripping through and cut a swath
through all the Green Lantern's
basically leading to the introduction of
Kyle Rayner as the last Green Lantern in
existence now that was the official
explanation as it was given by DC during
the events of Emerald Twilight of course
Hal Jordan declaring himself to be
parallax at the time was him just giving
himself a name of course with Geoff
Johns run and one of the things we've
talked about recently is that parallax
was an actual entity one of the entities
of the emotional spectrum that
represents fear and the result was that
Geoff Johns basically came back with a
retcon and said uh now during Emerald
Twilight Hal Jordan was literally
possessed by parallax's so because of
that I'm a kind of you know bolsters
things a little bit and gives us a a
pretty solid point on the character of
Hal Jordan where he's coming from but in
terms of the fallout is John's basically
setting the stage for the return of the
school Green Lanterns who are presumed
to have been killed when Hal Jordan
became parallax and destroyed the Green
Lantern Corps and the idea that there's
going to be fallout for the kind of
things that he's done now at this point
we jump over to sector 674 and pick up
with a guy named arkillo who's basically
told you have the power to instill great
fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps and that
is when the sort of special Corps war
basically starts this is it this is the
only thing we get with a semester off or
at least this little segment called
revenge of the Green Lantern's but the
funny thing about this is that when this
story came out and when it was like
welcome to the Sinestro Corps people
freaked I mean I didn't I wasn't reading
at the time I've actually gone back and
look at like old forum posts you know
Wayback Machine different things like
that and people were losing their minds
like they were just speculating all over
the place what does it mean you know
what's gonna happen
it was crazy you know that you know how
people were reacting to the whole thing
those are the guys who were around when
this story first came out I'm sure you
can attest to the same thing people were
losing their minds they're like why it's
a Sinestro Corps like it was it was a
crazy crazy thing to go through and just
read people's reactions and see them
kind of going crazy but the beginning of
revenge of the Green Lantern's it really
picks up with the arrival of tomar to
the Green Lantern of space sector to
eight one three who's one of the
original Green Lantern's that Hal Jordan
killed when he was paralyzed and so the
first question they have is what in the
world is going on here where did he come
from now what we're going over here
right now is a retcon that's literally
recovering at retcon here in real-time
of course those the guys who were new to
color books retcon means retroactive
continuity is simply that something
happened in a comic book a comic book
writer comes on it comes along later on
down the line and changes what
originally happened and that's what
geoff johns is gonna be doing here he's
basically gonna be retconning the
original Green Lantern's that were
killed by Hal Jordan operating as
parallax and show us that they're
actually alive and so again the cool
thing about this is that back Afiya the
Green Lantern Corps a citadel basically
you know the the you know on the planet
OA we basically have Hal Jordan dealing
with a lot of the fallout with regards
to how people view him and the reason
why is because of the fact that when the
new Green Lantern Corps was basically
being initiated they were being trained
they were being brought in word began to
spread about what Hal Jordan did when he
was parallax that he basically turned
against the Green Lantern Corps and
pushed it to the brink of almost
complete and total extinction and so
because of that a lot of people look at
him as a traitor they still look at him
as somebody who's a liar
somebody who
cannot be trusted now this is a
secondhand viewpoint right it's like if
I tell you something and then you take
it as gospel truth you believe it
because I told you not because you know
it to be true and so because of that
these guys are basically just kind of
going on what it is they've been told by
other people it's secondhand knowledge
at best and so again it kind of creates
an interesting scenario because what it
does is it basically has Jeff Jones
showing us what their allegiance to the
core really means despite the fact that
it's secondhand knowledge despite the
fact that they don't know that it's true
their allegiance to the Green Lantern
Corps means that they view Hal Jordan as
a traitor now the other half of this is
that they're also in fear for their own
lives now they're not they don't really
come out and show that instead what we
end up having are individuals who have
basically taken up the mantle of Green
Lantern for other people who were the
the Green Lantern of their sector before
Hal Jordan killed him for example one of
the guys at a tactile Jordan is
basically the next person to become
Green Lantern after their predecessor ki
Han I think is how you pronounce it was
supposedly killed by Hal Jordan as
though a lot of these guys are swearing
revenge they're saying look the Green
Lantern of my sector was killed by you
I'm the new Green Lantern and now you're
gonna die or at the very least they're
gonna be the absolute hell out of them
now of course Guy Gardner steps in right
and this is why fans loved Guy Gardner
because guy Gardner is like - come on
man
like you're killing me you really think
you stand a chance that's why people
love Guy Gardner is because he's so
cocky he's so arrogant but he's got it
where it counts
yeseo some some some guy gardner fans
are feeling hardened they're like damn
right Rob he does have it where it
counts and I'm sure some folks are just
like yeah man but uh but the fact
remains here that once the entire
conflict is basically quelled by by
Kilowog we end up having Hal Jordan
meeting with the guardians of the
universe now of course Hal Jordans
response here is hey look
tomar to basically arrived here he's
supposed to have been dead the fact that
he's alive means an investigation needs
to be launched now of course the
guardians of the universe are well aware
of the fact that tomar 2 is alive but
this is Geoff Johns kind of dipping into
the idea that the guardians of the
universe are a little duplicitous
they're not completely honest with the
Green Lantern's now it makes sense right
I mean when you're the President of the
United States you don't tell the
American people everything that's going
on because they don't need to know
everything that's going on and even if
they did of what use would that
information be to them you tell people
what they need to know and you let the
press deal with everything else the
press are the ones that disseminate that
information they gift people
it is it's going on but if you're
sitting with a president needs to say
look we're the Situation Room we have
this this this this this this and this
all going on you're gonna be overloaded
with information we're asked when you're
given that information contextually
based on this situation that you're in
then you can absorb it and you can use
it for what it's worth as opposed to
just kind of letting it sit in your
brain and then pass you by so again it's
not really keeping people from getting
any information that they need it's
making sure they get the information at
the right time but it presents a very
dangerous situation because if I'm a
holder of the keys and I'm guarding all
the doors you can only get in if I'd let
you well then what happens if I don't
want to let you in well then you can't
access whatever is on the other side
information is the exact same way and so
again it's basically us as you know
readers learning that the gardens of the
universe are holding information but the
fact that they're not benign the fact
that they are for the most part a little
mysterious they're very cloak-and-dagger
in terms of how they deal with the Green
Lantern's it means that they're not
giving out the essential information
that's necessary now with regards to Hal
Jordan his request for an investigation
of what's going on with regards to the
re-emergence of tomar - is immediately
declined this immediately turned down
the guardians like nope you do not need
to you do not need to do that simply
because of the fact that the the
destination of tomar 2 was traced back
to his intention to arrive on earth but
having originated beyond sector 3600 now
being beyond that sector 3600 basically
means you're beyond known space and if I
understand it correctly you're getting
into the realm of what's what's
basically beyond the source walk or just
at the source wall effectively you're
outside the patrolling area of the
guardians of the universe and so because
of that they basically say it's beyond
our sector beyond our ability to
basically function out there you know
you do not go there not only that the
Manhunters occupy that space out there
and of course the Guardians basically
say the reason why is because of the
fact that the Manhunters were able to
exist in that area because nothing can
survive out there
no no organic organism can survive on
its own now of course we end up having
Hal Jordan and Guy Gardner take off
anyway because what kind of Green
Lantern's would they be if they always
follow the rules and so again it's kind
of a it's kind of a funny scenario but
it's also how Jordan being you know
basically lying saying hey look yeah man
of course the guardians of the universe
sanctioned this mission why wouldn't
they I'm missing Green Lantern comes
back and they want to know what happened
of course Guy Gardner is along for the
ride now we as fans know
Gardner was born at night but he wasn't
born last night so he's well of where
what's going on with regards to what
he'll do Ernest telling him the problem
is that when they arrive to where it was
that tomar 2 had originated from they
just find a massive amount of man
hunters I mean literally just thousands
of man hunters all over the place almost
like a base of operations or giant
factory cranking them out and that's
exactly what this is is basically a
factory cranking out all these different
man hunters now these are the ones that
we had seen in Green Lantern no fear in
Volume one when we had this newest
iteration of Manhunter whose head was
basically a central power battery Praga
saw a power battery of sorts and
functioned for the purpose of absorbing
green lantern energy and so for this
reason with only Hal Jordan and Guy
Gardner being here they're on the ropes
and they constantly have to race against
the clock because if they spend more
than a couple of seconds in front of one
of these one of these man hunters their
rings are going to lose their charge and
they're going to be completely
defenseless and so while they're on
their way to basically racing a safety
trying to find a place where they can
recoup where they can basically regain
their energies allow their rings to
charge and jump back into the fray they
end up coming across the bodies of some
of the most prominent Green Lantern's
that were killed by Hal Jordan himself
when he was parallax of course all this
is revealed to have been orchestrated by
cyborg superman by hank henshaw now what
this does is it requires us to kind of
sidetrack for a little bit and it
requires us to actually jump back to a
story in 1996 I think it was called
final night and what final night did is
it basically kind of detailed the the
last little tidbit of Hal Jordan and
parallax with regards to you know the
the pre Jeff John's run on Green Lantern
and what we basically found out here was
that because cyborg superman alongside
mongrel had obliterated the entirety of
of coast city leading to I think I said
Central City earlier but in a play rate
of the entirety of coast city leading to
Hal Jordan becoming parallax in the
first place despite all the things that
he had done Hal Jordan looked at cyborg
superman as the one guy he needed to get
revenge on and so basically he fought
him at the edge of the universe
basically obliterated a cyborg superman
using his constructs and that was the
end of him now there was a little
segment with like Superman red superman
blue where they met cyborg superman and
so on and so forth we don't need to
worry about that that was not very good
storytelling but with regards to what it
is a Jeff Jones is doing here
this is
when the retcon begins to come into play
because what we're basically told is
that after having basically destroyed
the body of cyborg superman during final
night that he reconstituted his physical
body but the result is that he also came
across the Manhunters their programming
what it was designed for and effectively
modified them so for those of you guys
who have been huge fans of Marvel Comics
and who are reading anihilation conquest
think about anihilation conquest
basically being the same thing as this
of course this comes long before
conquests but the fact remains think of
them as basically being almost identical
and annihilation conquest
Ultron's physical body was destroyed his
consciousness took over the Phalanx and
he basically began constructing an
empire that's exactly what's happening
here with cyborg Superman now the idea
here is that this is Geoff Johns
basically teasing the whole the whole
concept of Hal Jordan being pure
willpower now of course this is
something that won't really be explored
until we get to like Robert vendetta's
run with Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern's as part of DC rebirth but it
was basically the case that that Geoff
Johns was making the entire time know
Green Lantern will ever be as capable as
Hal Jordan at least as us being
portrayed here now the great thing is
that Geoff Johns is gonna grow and he's
gonna expand the Green Lantern's and so
we're gonna see characters playing some
pretty significant roles and everybody's
gonna get their chance everybody's gonna
get their their time in the Sun my
gardener Kyle Rayner
Jon Stewart all these different versions
they're all gonna get their time in the
Sun so again it's gonna be pretty cool
to see this life shine on everybody the
issue with this is that when Hal Jordan
basically overcomes the attempt of
cyborg superman to override his brain
using you know nanites that basically
hook him up to machine and siphon off
his his Green Lantern energy his
willpower Hal Jordan basically wakes up
key han this Green Lantern that we
thought had since been destroyed now the
funny thing is that in the moment aki
han basically sees Manhunters and just
starts tearing things up but then how
Jordan starts going through and waking
up all of these different individuals
Lyra for example and chants and you know
graphed horan and and and boodikka I
think it is how you pronounce it I'm not
100% sure but begins waking up all these
different Green Lantern's the issue is
that once the immediate threat of the
Manhunters is taken care of at least
temporarily they immediately attack Hal
Jordan and the reason why is because for
them time hasn't passed from the time
that they had essentially died : unquote
actually the time they woke up here it
was moments it was like if you blinked
your eyes or like if you fell asleep or
something like that no time has passed
for them
as far as they know how Jordan is still
paralyzed so they're living there
basically still living in 1993-1994
Emerald Twilight and the idea that Hal
Jordan is a bad guy and trying to attack
them now of course all this begins to
more or less wind down when torn
basically says guys stop if Hal Jordan
was still parallax he would have killed
us all by now the fact that he's not
fighting is an indication that something
else is going on here so this is when
the air is cleared slightly and he
basically tells them hey look you guys
have been here four years now of course
they still don't trust him they still do
not trust Hal Jordan and there's no
reason for them to but it's basically a
scenario of the enemy of my enemy is my
friend in the sense that they're
temporary allies with Hal Jordan because
it's in their best interest to work
together to defeat cyborg superman and
the Manhunters after which someone is
gonna pay in spades
so what we also end up doing here is we
basically pick up with the return of a
character named arisia at least I think
it's it's ERISA or Arista we're gonna
call her arisia - sathya is a much
better like a cool way to say her name
but not only is she prevalent here but
there's also a litany of Green Lantern's
a multitude of individuals who have just
gone missing over the years or whatever
the case may be and so of course in the
middle of these old-school lanterns what
we're gonna call them in the middle of
these old-school answer is basically
realizing that so many other lanterns
are here the entire group is basically
attacked by Guy Gardner who's been
pulled and and basically attached to the
inside of a of a giant Manhunter robot
so again this shows us what the goal of
cyborg superman is to essentially
harness Green Lantern's use their energy
use them as as literal batteries to
power these massive devices that he's
made for himself and begin the process
of universal conquests not from here
Geoff Johns and this is really the only
time I know of where he really seems to
invoke this lease on what I've read so
far but Geoff Johns really just kind of
invokes this easy way out retcon Geoff
Johns I love you man I love everything
you do and and man I'd love to get
something signed by you one day but it
kind of cracked me up when I saw this
because it was like well I mean like
cyborgs two men basically says well you
know whenever they're in a state of
duress whenever they are basically you
know what they're considered to have
been dead individuals from from Braxton
who are really from the from the crotch
in territories those individuals
basically go through and they experience
the equivalent of a Kryptonian a healing
coma that's really what they end up
going through um
funny to see that juxtaposition between
you know what Jeff Jones was doing here
and the return of Superman the
difference is that most people in fact a
lot of people did not give DC a pass
when it came to the return of Superman
but they give Jeff Jones a pass when it
came to the Green Lantern now I would
surmise this is really because of the
fact that it's not a plot device it's
actually designed to basically give us
something that we wouldn't normally get
or something that's intriguing because
the survival of arisia is not important
to the story by any standard of
measurement she could not be here she
could still be dead and the story would
continue on just fine it's not like
Geoff Johns backed himself into a wall
and needed an easy way out it's not like
that at all instead a ryssia is an
intrinsic part of the Hal Jordan
landscape in the sense that the two of
them were lovers for quite some time now
of course following Hal Jordan becoming
parallax the last fig leaf so to speak
was the fact that a risky basically said
hey look he will come back like he will
come back to his normal self now of
course the shoot was killed by major
force who in turn was killed by Guy
Gardner but the fact remains here that
her return means that there's somebody
out there who sees redemption for Hal
Jordan and that's why this is important
Guy Gardner will always be in his corner
no matter what happens you know Jon
Stewart will always be a friend of Hal
Jordan I mean I wouldn't say that he'll
be in his corner of no matter what I
mean he'll come a point where Jon
Stewart's like okay look how like you
got a dime and like this is not okay but
Arisa was the one who always had faith
in health that he would always come back
she's the bright shining star in his
life and so this is basically Geoff
Johns bringing her back and saying hey
look guys it's not bleak it's not dark
it's not hopeless we need to have some
hope in what's going on in the Green
Lantern landscape especially with the
stories that are getting ready to come
up so again you know this this fight
between cyborg superman anda and Hal
Jordan is relatively short-lived in the
sense that where Hank Henshaw initially
gets the upper hand
Larissa's ring activates she jumps back
into the fray and the two of them start
facing off against Hank Henshaw
who is basically believed to have been
destroyed but the fact remains here that
with the with the central core basically
of this planet being destroyed the
planet itself basically explodes as
completely and totally eradicated and so
jumping back to the Citadel of the
Guardians on OA
we of course have Guy Gardner covering
for how Guy Gardner of look is of course
he's since been made a member of the
honor guard and the Green Lantern Corps
and because of that he's allowed three
strikes until he loses his position and
his
possibly even banned from the Green
Lantern corn so because of this he
basically just takes one of his
lifelines he says yeah man like I gave
him permission to go on this mission of
course it was an area was my mistake
two more shots and then I'll be done so
you know just I'll worry about that then
but the problem is he still has to be
punished and so because of that he's
assigned to basically spend time a month
on prime duty and what that means is
he's going to be one of the guys who
guards superboy-prime in his science
cell day in and day out every day for
one month so it's gonna it's gonna suck
it's a really crappy job but again this
is basically Jeff Sean saying hey guys
less we forget superboy-prime is still
there superboy-prime is still being held
by the Green Lantern's and the reason
why is because as we know with Sinestro
Corps war a superboy-prime is going to
come back alright so getting into how
Jordan wanted this is one of those Green
Lantern stories that's really really
important and in fact there's there's
actually a couple of those in Jeff Jones
run where they're just really important
Green Lantern stories and that's why
you'll find different reading orders for
Green Lantern in terms of like essential
reading stuff that you can skip over
stuff that you have to read different
things like that
but this story Hal Jordan wanted will be
required and the reason why is because
what this does is it sets the stage for
the introduction of the Sinestro Corps
as well as the star sapphires so again
this is pretty important here it's a
pretty big deal now initially what this
does is it actually gives us a little
bit of a prequel in the sense that this
is kind of a little bit of what happened
before this coming picked up so it's
really kind of between the last three
Lantern story arc and this current you
know Green Lantern's story all this all
just really kind of took place off panel
but essentially what had happened is a
Hal Jordan alongside Jillian Pearlman
going by the name cowgirl so we'll just
go ahead and call our cowgirl and Shane
ashamed sellers who goes by the name
Rocket Man
I had basically been taken prisoner
while they were on a mission for the Air
Force now the reason why this happened
is because Hal Jordan himself really
prides on the idea of never taking his
Green Lantern ring with him whenever
he's flying now the reason why this is
the case is because one it gives them a
sense of urgency and it allows them to
kind of see the danger of the situation
the reason being because of the fact
that in the instance whatever he's
flying a jet the Green Lantern ring is a
crutch more so than anything else but
it's also Jeff John's giving to us the
reckless nature of Hal Jordan and that's
why those two things kind of go
hand-in-hand with regards to the idea of
the lantern being your crotch it's
really one of those things where if how
Jordan has his Lantern ring with him
then he knows that no matter what would
happen while he's flying that jet if it
malfunctions and explodes if he flies in
enemy territory and gets shot down
whatever the case may be it would
ultimately lead to the idea that he will
always be okay because the ring will
automatically do what it needs to do to
preserve his life assuming that he loses
consciousness if he is conscious all he
has to do is just fire up the ring and
then he's all set and he can rescue
whoever it is is with him assuming that
they you know they're falling to their
deaths or something along those lines I
mean if they pop parachutes and they're
in friendly territory they'll be fine
you know but if they're an enemy
territory he can use his ring rescue
them fly them back to the United States
and the day is saved if he doesn't have
his ring that it means that he has to be
on his guard all the time now in terms
of the reckless nature that's the other
half of this equation despite the fact
that he knows it it's necessary for him
to keep his eye out on everything that's
going on to make sure that he's always
paying attention listening to the people
around him what it also does is it
allows him to basically put his life on
the line every single time he flies and
again that's just the reckless nature of
Hal Jordan but what Geoff Johns run is
designed to do is to provide so much
character development for Hal and that's
why how we see him with regards to the
later stories especially in light Hal g1
and the Green Lantern Corps rebirth
seems so different from how we see him
here and how we saw him in secret origin
because he basically grew up he
basically moved away from being just so
wildly reckless he was still a little
bit reckless but it wasn't like I don't
care if I live or die it wasn't one of
those philosophies it was hey look I can
be reckless but I also have to recognize
other people's lives are on the line
here and so again kind of walking that
fine line is one of the things that made
his character so intriguing for a lot of
different people but the reason why this
is important is because of the fact that
in his mind had he been wearing his
Green Lantern ring neither how Nord
cowgirl or Rocket Man would have been
captured as soon as their jets were shot
down he would have donned his Green
Lantern uniform he would have saved them
he would have whisked off and then he
probably would have gone back and you
know fought against whoever it was that
shot them down in the first place the
fact that he wasn't able to makes him
feel like a failure now the other half
of this is that in this moment right now
in this particular instance cowgirl was
sent on yet another mission she was shot
down and she was taken prisoner by Tara
so because of this how jordan's more or
less on a mission to find and save her
and it's kind of him basically in this
position where he's trying to fix his
past mistakes now another aspect of this
is that cowgirl and hal jordan do share
somewhat of romance the difference here
is that the romance they share is
nothing like what he had with carol
fairs with carol ferris it was a lot
more intimate it was a lot more personal
it was really the possibility that they
could have shared a life together now
that's the old school back in the day
Carol Ferris and Hal Jordan really one
of the things that Geoff Johns kind of
worked on with the idea of the
characters was to essentially create
this romantic tension will they won't
they that kind of thing you know now of
course it really was a scenario where
Carol Ferris essentially said look you
know I run a business you work for me
that's where the relationship stops but
the question was always asked by fans
are they going to get together is Carol
Ferris going to be the lowest lane of
Hal Jordans life is she going to be the
damsel in distress the one he always
saves the ones he would go to the ends
of the earth to make sure that she stay
protected and so that seems to be the
implication here - Hal and Carol that
maybe they'll go along that direction
now of course you know we know there's
some struggle and strife in between but
the fact remains here that with regards
to Hal Jordan trying to track down these
terrorists ultimately he's met with a
global Guardians now keep in mind this
is all post Infinite Crisis and the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that DC use Infinite Crisis as
a way to reinvigorate and relaunch
different characters and teams it was
much like when Marvel had their Avengers
disassembled than they launched Hausa
BAM then they gave us New Avengers
alright with regards to DC's Infinite
Crisis we had the global Guardians then
we had Infinite Crisis and then we had
the global Guardians relaunched and
revamped as an entirely new team
designed for the purpose of giving us a
new roster new individuals so on and so
forth now under normal circumstances the
global guardians are superheroes but the
way they're conducting themselves here
are as villains and they were really
kind of like a background theme with
regards to Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern we didn't really you know we
wouldn't really do a whole lot of
discussion with them just because you
know you'd have like a single panel or a
single page and it would have taken away
from the overall flow of the discussion
that we were having at the time but
effectively every single time they made
an appearance and Geoff Johns Green
Lantern so far the Hal Jordan stories
ultimately it seemed like they were
reporting to somebody else or working
for somebody else and they were looking
to track down Hal Jordan and to
basically take him prisoner and so
what seems to be taking place here is
that someone somewheres put a bounty on
the head of Hal Jordan and what we end
up finding out is that the person that's
done this is a guy by the name of Ayman
sewer the son of a band saw now the
reason why this is important is because
of the fact that this is Geoff Johns
harkening all the way back to the secret
origin of Hal Jordan when he first
gained his lantern range and the idea
was that when that happened Aven soar
had basically crash-landed on earth and
he had told his ring go find somebody
worthy of becoming a Green Lantern now
this is where Jeff Jones kind of plays
it fast and loose in terms of how the
Green Lantern rings function which is
kind of ironic because he's pretty
tedious in terms of the nature of the
Lantern rings who can wield what rings
what determines their worthiness or
their ability to wield it and that kind
of thing but on the whole the idea seems
to be that whenever a Green Lantern dies
the ring will basically say you know
Green Lantern of sector whatever
deceased seeking out a new Green Lantern
seeking out a new host it seems as
though the rings will basically seek out
the most worthy person in the immediate
vicinity and then just race them back to
OA just because it makes the most sense
right I mean if a Green Lantern dies the
immediate job is to keep that number
going one Green Lantern dies one takes
their place the integrity of the Green
Lantern course in number is maintained
so there will always be 5200 or 5400 I
came over how many there are right now
but the fact remains that that number
will always be maintained the issue here
is that Amon sorr basically takes the
stance that as the as the son of Aven
soar he should have been the one to
receive his father's ring but the
indication here is that it doesn't work
that way
the Lantern rings don't automatically
pass down based on genealogy you know
the son is not guaranteed to get his
father's rank there's times where that
happens that's true but for whatever
reason the ring immediately sought out
Hal Jordan instead of a manned sewer and
this really seem to make the sense
because of the fact that a mr. was on
the other side of the universe and so it
was just kind of a circumstance I sort
of worked itself out that way now the
reason why I say this story is so
important is because what we do is we
transition to a place called Salsbury
England and there is basically some girl
that's getting macked on by some guy and
in this guy's you know trying to trying
to make some moves when she comes across
a glowing corporal pink gym now of
course this gym communicates directly
with her and says here's the real
motivations of the Scot this guy doesn't
really care about you this guy's not
really interested in you this guy is
only after one thing now of course when
the girl picks up this gym it bonds with
her and she becomes a star sapphire now
of course again this is really kind of a
cool scenario because all of this is
leading up to the formation of the star
sapphires you know to their evolution as
a team that's one of the reasons why I
wanted to bring that up and so what we
end up doing is we actually end up
jumping back to Hal Jordan again and so
ultimately we end up finding out that
there are a group of individuals I
believe they're called the faceless
hunters um but they were basically
telepathically controlling the global
Guardians and that's the reason why the
global Guardians were working directly
against their normal role as superheroes
and trying to track down Hal Jordan
because of the fact that a Mansouri put
this bounty out on Hal Jordans head
really these these faceless guys were
one of the many people who responded and
were using the global Guardians as a way
to track down how now this made sense if
you were a man just because of the fact
that it's really just a way to keep
yourself away from being you know
intervene or being mixed into the whole
frame you know it's one of those things
where if you're gonna issue a bounty you
don't do it yourself you issue a bat let
you send out a bounty you hire a guy who
hires a guy who hires a guy that
initiates the bounty that way there's so
many lines of buffering there's so much
confusion and conflicts in there no one
can ever feasibly trace it back to you
not only that in the midst of all this
conflict and in the midst of all this
chaos and so on we actually end up
joining up with Alan Scott m's as well
as the rest of the Justice League when
they arrived on the scene now Alan Scott
presents kind of a funny scenario and
the reason why is because of the fact
that he's a Green Lantern but not a
Green Lantern at the same time and this
is actually very important when it comes
to the character of Kyle Rayner and
we'll have that discussion once we get
to like you know ion and the torch
bearer and that kind of thing but the
fact remains that Alan Scott is
basically empowered by mystical energies
from another universe from earth to
again it gets kind of crazy and so I
think that's a discussion this best
isolated to context because really it's
kind of the power of Alan Scott that was
sort of pushed into Kyle Rayner that
makes him so unique he has the power of
the Green Lantern's and the power of the
star heart but again that's really more
of kind of like a Colerain of thing but
you know Alan Scott again I think people
kind of find him confusing because one
of the big questions they have is we've
got the traditional Green Lantern's of
Jon Stewart you know Kyle Rayner and how
Dror
and Kilowog all that kind of stuff and
then we have alan scott just kind of out
there in left field
how does he reside what's the basis
behind his power so we might be like an
origin video or something along those
lines where it kind of explains the
basis behind his powers and what he's
capable of if for no other reason than
to kind of you know shine a little light
on the whole concept of his character
but the fact remains here that with Hal
Jordan more less making his escape you
know kind of tracking down who it was
the initiated all you know all these
bounties and the Justice League
essentially dealing with the fallout we
end up joining him once he's captured by
a manned sewer and what we end up
finding out is that again a man's sword
really did all of this just for the
purpose of getting ahold of what he
believed to be his father's ring of
stepping in to the rightful heir of the
next Green Lantern following the death
of his father essentially taking Hal
Jordans place but in the middle of all
this we actually kind of jumped back to
the Justice League for a second and we
actually end up joining with Batman in
Gotham City fighting against you know
some of his own foes and then out of the
middle of nowhere suddenly it's Bruce
Wayne of the planet Earth you have the
ability to instill great fear welcome to
the Sinestro Corps there was a moment
where Batman was part of the Sinestro
Corps and it's so cool because they they
basically say you've been chosen to
represent space sector two eight one
four the issue with this is that
Batman's willpower is so extreme that he
actually overrides the yellow lantern
ring he override his ability to take
possession of him and so because of that
the yellow lantern ring basically says
look you've got too much willpower
you're better suited as a Green Lantern
than a yellow lantern and essentially
just kind of bails out and goes and
searches for a more suitable host now
the ring kind of says that it rejects
him and true that's really more like
Batman rejecting the ring but this is
one of the cool things you know now the
reason why this also happened is
remember we had covered this in one of
our previous videos Batman used the
Green Lantern ring by Hal Jordan it was
only for a moment Hal Jordan gave it to
Batman so Batman could make constructs
of his parents and help to kind of move
past all his regret and all his remorse
over his parents deaths but the fact
that he was able to use a Green Lantern
ring means he's best suited for a Green
Lantern ring as opposed to a Sinestro
Corps ring so the Sinestro Corps ring
really kind of looks at him as tainted
really kind of looks at him as hey look
you've got Green Lantern energy on you
and then of course goes and searches off
a new house but the funny thing about
this is that when it happens Batman's
response was like what the hell was that
it was really kind of funny it's just
like this quick thing because it
happened so fast I mean honestly it
probably takes it probably takes place
over the span of like like five seconds
right like the ring pops up Bruce Wayne
you have the power to instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps you'll be
subjected to training he's like what the
hell is like get off of me and then like
the Rings like up air and then it takes
off and it just it happened so fast he's
just like what in the hell this is
really funny to see that happen but in
the midst of this whole this whole
attempt by Amon sort to basically you
know kill Hal Jordan to essentially take
over the role of his father ultimately
the ring that rejected Batman binds
itself to Amon Sewer kissably says
you've been inducted into the Sinestro
Corps you have the power to instill
great fear that kind of thing now again
this is Geoff Johns bringing in the idea
of the Sinestro Corps and that's how it
works that's how geoff johns does this
and that's why it's so cool initially it
starts out as a trickle a character
somewhere on another planet and suddenly
inducted into the Sinestro Corps and
that's it that's the only thing you get
you just get like one panel where it's
like you have the ability to instill
great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps and you're
just like what and then you don't hear
hide nor hair of the Sinestro Corps for
three or four volumes of books for like
seven story arcs you don't hear anything
and then suddenly a masseur shows up on
earth tries to kill Hal Jordan and he's
brought into the Sinestro Corps
that's why geoff johns writing works so
well because we get this great big huge
grandiose Sinestro Corps war storyline
with a green LED or I guess the
guardians of the universe has to totally
restructure how the Green Lantern rings
work why because over the course these
little tidbits here and there this story
here that story there that story over
there the Sinestro Corps was slowly
introduced but the longer the stories go
on the more people get brought in the
bigger the whole revelation of the
Sinestro Corps becomes so instead of
just one person gets inducted in the
Sinestro Corps and a single comic subtly
it's three people are brought into the
Sinestro Corps and then seven people are
brought into the Sinestro Corps and the
numbers just keep getting bigger and
bigger and so it's literally an incoming
book build up to this insanely good
story because I'll allow many of the
guys read Sinestro Corps war it is
amazing it is such a good story man it's
absolutely love let me tell you
something if God was right in Green
Lantern that's exactly what it would
look like Sinestro Corps war it is an
amazing story so what we in
doing here is we pick up with the tail
end of this conversation or I guess a
tail into this video and of course we're
Hal Jordan kind of goes to pay his
respects to AB and sewer realizing that
Abin hadn't had a son because again this
is the first time that he knew that
Avenue sewer had a son of course he
really kind of modifies his gravestone
to say you know he was he was also a
father you know paying respects to the
family to the legacy that Avenue sewer
had created and that sort of thing but
we also pick up in Northern California
just outside Ferris air and what we end
up having is this woman the first star
sapphire that we saw here crash lands
and the idea is that these star sapphire
is jumping from host to host finding a
way to reconnect itself with Hal Jordan
once again okay so after going through
and reworking my schedule trying to get
it all sorted out trying to get
everything organized
God man the biggest problem that I have
is there's so many things I want to
cover and there's just not enough days
to cover them that's the biggest problem
otherwise I'd be doing like different
videos every single day and it just it
gets confusing and crazy but Green
Lantern and like really because of Geoff
Johns run because of how big it is it's
gonna be one of those things that we
just kind of do where we have room to
put it and we'll just do it on our
classic DC day and then you know once
like Justice League when the movie comes
out will actually put green lantern on
hole to cover new 52 Justice League and
then come back to Green Lantern again
but what this story does really this
this sort of ions story is it a lot of
ways it's self-contained
I mean really it's not technically part
of the greater Green Lantern's story but
it does give us some pretty important
things with regards to Kyle Rayner and
really kind of elevates him above all
the other Green Lantern's making him
somebody of pretty of a pretty high
level of significance in relation to
every other Green Lantern ever in the
sense that he holds a special place now
this will also become important once we
get to the idea of Kyle Rayner becoming
the white Lantern and all those
different kinds of things so again it's
really kind of an important bit here but
what this does is it actually deals
initially with the idea of Kyle Rayner
losing his mind Kyle Rayner going crazy
and actually attacking a few of the
other Green Lantern's now the reason why
this matters is remember we have our
video where we talk about like the power
of the star heart and again where you'll
find that down in the description but it
basically means that at this moment
right now kyle rayner wields two sources
of power he reeled wields a star heart
which is basically all this magical
energy from another universe as well as
the traditional Green Lantern powers
that are given to him by the
virtue of a Green Lantern ring and so
the cool thing about this is that well
he doesn't necessarily reel the ring per
se he does have this insane source of
energy about him and so again it makes
things pretty interesting in terms of
how he functions and in terms of what he
does because he's basically got two sets
of powers combined into one now the
reason why this happens and what seems
to be going well going on with Kyle
Rayner in terms of him being insane is
that he'll black out he'll basically go
through these instances where he just
sort of lashes out he'll lose his temper
he'll attack people and then he'll black
out and wake up somewhere else in this
instance following this attack on these
other members of the Green Lantern's he
simply wakes up back at home where he
meets up with a guy by the name of
Schuler I think it is and it's really
just him just kind of learning how to be
a better artist remember being an artist
is part of Kyle Raynor's full repertoire
now the reason why this matters and the
reason why this part of the story is
being told is because for a lot of
people keep in mind Geoff Johns run on
Green Lantern was their introduction to
Green Lantern and so really like Ron
Marz Jeff John these guys they could not
come along and basically just throw cara
wayne her in there without giving any
explanation of who he is or what he's
about now he does make small references
to things like his past you know
relationships the fact that the the I
guess the history has his various women
have always been pretty much
unsuccessful in the sense but for the
most part they've all died this really
comes by way of the fact of a girl who's
basically moved in on the property where
you know these various artists reside
and she doesn't say anything she doesn't
speech doesn't address anybody and when
the question is asked Mike how waiter
who this girl is of course Shuler
basically says look she doesn't talk but
for him he thinks back you know to his
first major girlfriend who was killed by
major force I think it was and then
stuffed into a fridge I mean there's all
these different instances in his
characters history where his
relationships with women just never
really work out they usually I'll end up
dying but in terms of Kyle Rayner
himself and what he means the first
indication of this comes from the
guardians of the universe who are
basically watching all this on for now
keep in mind in the Green Lantern
landscape the guardians are very
cloak-and-dagger they do not tell the
Green Lantern's anything unless they
need to know the Guardians keep a lot of
secrets to themselves now this creates
some measure of distrust among the Green
Lantern's especially with Hal Jordan who
doesn't view them as necessarily
trustworthy but views them as necessary
in the sense that maybe they're holding
that information because people don't
need to know but again it creates kind
of a rift between the two groups because
there are oftentimes things where the
Green Lantern's just want to know what
going on but the Guardians won't tell
them what it is that's happening this is
really significant with regards to
Kilowog and a lot of the members who are
part of the Green Lantern Corps when
these injured members of the lanterns
that were attacked by Kyle Rayner land
on OA and when the questions asked what
happened and they say Kyle Rayner
basically lost his mind he attacked us
we don't know why the response of the
Guardians is no one is to intervene with
what's going on with Kyle Rayner you do
not offer him aid and you stay out of
his way you let him be now again this is
kind of crazy because it's basically you
know these members of the Green Lantern
Corps learning that one of their guys is
basically kind of going awry and seeming
to have some kind of crisis you know and
laying waste to innocent people out
there but the guardians are basically
saying you cannot intervene on his
behalf you have to let him go so again
this is pretty tough it's really really
hard for any of the members of the Green
Lantern Corps to actually do on their
own but ultimately they're made to and
again we continue to see these
experiences of Kyle Rayner blacking out
of Kyle Rayner not knowing what's going
on just kind of waking up in the
aftermath of all this destruction and
having no idea what's happening now of
course this will be explained and we'll
find out what it is that's going on but
while this is taking place we actually
have Kilowog sneaking off a message to a
member of the Green Lantern Corps for
the purpose of saying hey look Kyle
winters basically lost his mind you have
to go out and find him and you have to
bring him back now this again also kind
of shows us the solace that goes on
between the members of the the Green
Lantern Corps in the sense that in a
cilok who basically speaks on behalf of
the Guardians and kind of upholds the
laws that they passed appears to kill a
wall kind of asking him what it is that
you were doing you know what's going on
and then ultimately says look if you
hadn't done it I would have now again
this is cool because it shows us the
standing that Kyle Rayner has among the
Green Lantern Corps remember going all
the way back to Emerald Twilight and so
on and so forth Hal Jordan is always
viewed with a slanted eye even if he's a
good guy now even if he's fighting on
behalf of the Green Lantern's even if
he's trying to repent for his actions
under the name of parallax he's still
viewed as someone that can't really be
trusted by the Green Lantern's but Kyle
Rayner does not hold that struggle Kyle
Rayner has always been there he's like
the the Dick Grayson of the Green
Lantern Corps he's this bright shining
light that everybody always trusts and
so because of that we end up finding out
that in the midst of him basically
passing out and going through one of his
episodes that Kyle Rayner basically
stumbles upon Mogo the Green Lantern
planet now
and this is part of the guardians of the
universe plan but we don't know it yet
we simply know that mojo is there and
the cool thing about this is that Kyle
Raynor begins going through and having
these visions of various people that
he's had of course one of the first
major relationships that he had the girl
named Alex you know it's kind of cool
meeting with her because we get to sort
of go back and do this tour of Kyle
Reiner's life the woman that he's known
and the women that he's lost the
failures that he's had over the course
of his Green Lantern career you know
whether he meets Alex whether he meets
Donna Troy regardless of what person he
runs into it's basically this ongoing
concept you know Jade the daughter of
Alan Scott the one who gave how into the
power of the star heart you know all
these different things come together for
this idea of Kyle Waner having his own
doubts that for him he does not view
himself as a worthy Green Lantern he
views himself worthy in so far that the
other members of the Green Lantern Corps
trust him to a degree he views himself
worthy insofar that he's allowed to
wield the ring because he has the
willpower to do it if a ring is what he
needs to pull off the things that he
does but at the end of the day he does
not see himself as a worthy Green
Lantern he sees himself as a guy who's
made too many mistakes now this is cool
because what this does is it shows us
that the ghosts of parallax still
lingers on the ghost of Hal Jordan
losing his mind wiping out the Green
Lantern Corps Kyle Rayner being the last
remaining Green Lantern it still lingers
on it's still very much a part of who he
is and what he's about and his biggest
fear is that he will become Hal Jordan
his biggest fear is that he will become
parallax somewhere along the line all
these losses that he's experienced all
these perceived failures that he's gone
through will come home to roost it's
really this idea that Hal Jordan had a
huge role in the life of Kyle Rayner and
the fact that Kyle Rayner is afraid of
falling down the same path now the
reason why this is so important it's
because of the fact the person we find
out - Kilowog was talking to is Hal
Jordan himself and so what's basically
been happening is Hal Jordan has been
following this trail of destruction by
Kyle Rayner and basically tracing him
back to his own particular location of
course this again brings us back to Kyle
Rayner back on the planet of Mogo and
after facing off against all these
threats that he's had facing off against
major force for example the guy who was
responsible for the death of Alex the
guy who is responsible for the death of
Jade for these women who are important
in the life of Kyle Rayner facing
against made
force is effectively Kyle Rayner facing
off against all the major issues and all
the struggles that he has now again
major force is not actually here Donna
Troy is not actually here Alex is not
actually here they are constructs
manifested by Mogo himself but it's
designed to force Kyle Rayner to face
himself he's basically facing who he is
everything that he's ever done every
mistake he's ever made in every fear he
ever has the reason why this is
important is because this covers the
emotional spectrum I mean think about it
fear rage hope death life all these
things represent the emotional spectrum
every single one he's basically proving
himself to be a master of he's
overcoming his fear
he's overcoming the fact that sometimes
people die and there's nothing you can
do to stop them he's overcoming the idea
that life has its own pattern has its
own form you know people are born and
they die he's facing his rage and his
anger with major force this is the first
step that Kyle Rayner takes to becoming
the white lantern so that's why this is
so important and so with Kyle Wade are
having a Green Lantern ring overcoming
all these things allows him to
effectively cast the ring aside and be a
power source unto himself and that's
really the test that the Guardians of
the Universe were forcing him to undergo
now of course the answer still has to be
asked why were these blackouts taking
place why was Kyle Rayner effectively
losing his mind well of course what is
up happening here is we actually find
out there's - Kyle Rayner running around
here there's the Kyle Rayner on the
planet of Mogo and there's a Kyle Rayner
who's running around tearing things up
and ripping things apart now of course
Hal Jordan catches up to the to the bad
to the evil car a nerd so to speak and
as the two of them end up doing battle
with one another what we end up finding
out is the real Kyle Rayner actually
shows up and that's the crazy scenario
here because while Hal Jordan is talking
to this evil Kyle Rayner this evil Kyle
Rayner almost seems to be himself he's
talking about the terrible things that
he's done trying to make up remorse
trying to do the right thing trying to
be a good person but ultimately lashes
out and begins attacking Hal Jordan and
so with the arrival of the good Kyle
Rayner with the arrival of the real Kyle
Rayner himself what we find out is that
this false Kyle laner is a guy named
Alex Niro now the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that with
regards to the Green Lantern landscape
this is yet another inch
of Geoff Johns and Ron Marz grabbing
these different eras of the Green
Lantern mythos and sort of rolling them
all together and the reason why I say
this is because of the fact that back
when you know how Jordan was the Green
Lantern afore he became parallax a
semester was always his main villain you
know Sinestro was Green Lantern's Lex
Luthor's so to speak but when Hal Jordan
was basically removed from the DC
landscape as the Green Lantern and Kyle
Rayner was put in his place
DC needed to give Kyle Rayner his own
arch-nemesis now of course this
eventually came in the form of major
force but Niro was really one of the one
of the attempts of DC to give Kyle
Rayner his own bad guy in the sense that
Neera was basically given a power ring
by the court Ian's those individuals in
the in the antimatter universe who are
responsible for giving Sinestro his
first power ring and so the idea was to
kind of try to repeat the past only
updating it for the modern day the issue
was that it just didn't really work that
great it worked to a degree but it
didn't really work that great but again
this was basically in addition that was
added in the early 2000s 2001 or step
along those lines and so the idea was
that with Alexander Nero somebody who
was basically suffering from mental
disorder that he would be the perfect
nemesis against Kyle Rayner
and this is kind of a cool thing here
because in this battle that we see
between Hal Jordan and Kyle as well as
Nero Nero is just basically creating all
these yellow constructs these fear-based
constructs now again this is kind of
hitting home at the original origin of
Nero but is also throwing into the idea
that the yellow Lantern Corps is growing
in number that the yellow Lantern Corps
is becoming something to worry about now
the Green Lantern's don't know this yet
they don't know that Sinestro was siming
rings out across the universe and
bolstering the race of his yellow
Lantern Corps you know all they know is
that this guy Nero shows up and this guy
is basically trying to confront people
as Kyle Rayner now the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that what
Nero basically says is he was taken by
the court Ian's this whole introduction
here he was taken by the chord Ian's and
he was basically forced to become Kyle
Rayner and basically discredit Kyle
Rayner as a Green Lantern hoping that it
would basically create a scenario where
Cowen would ultimately be taken down now
of course this was only one stage of the
operation the second stage was for Nero
to be captured and be taken to you the
guardians of the universe and the reason
why this matters is because of the fact
that after Nero is defeated by they
combined efforts of of Kyle
in Hal Jordan and Nero is taken to the
guardians of the universe themselves
what we end up finding out here is that
we're Kyle Rayner says he wants answers
he wants to know what in the world is
going on here you know what it is of the
guardians of the universe have been
doing and someone so forth we find out
that Nero was basically a bomb that Nero
was designed to basically explode with
all this yellow lantern energy and wipe
out the guardians of the universe and
the process now before that happens
we do get answers in terms of what it is
that's going on and what we find out
here is that Kyle Rayner all you know
though the whole idea with Nero was not
expected instead Kyle Rayner was
basically supposed to beat with mojo and
Moga was supposed to basically you know
force him to endure all these different
scenarios meeting Alex and Donna truly
and all the things that we saw with him
facing off against his own fears and his
own past and so on and so forth and the
reason why is because of the fact that
this is Geoff Johns and Ron Mars doing
something with Kyle Rayner this is why I
said we'd wait until around the end of
the video to cover all this when Kyle
Rayner was introduced as the Green
Lantern as DC began to progress his
character they reintroduced him as the
character of ion meaning that he had the
power of the Green Lantern and he had
the power of the star heart the problem
with this was that there was no real
indication of what this meant now of
course we ended up finding out that he
had an insane amount of power and then
he used almost all the energy he had to
basically recreate the Green Lantern's
central power battery to resurrect the
guardians of the universe and to restore
the Green Lantern Corps the reason why
this matters is because of the fact that
following that his power was basically
moved away from him being a god and back
down to normal levels but he was still
being called ion so the question had to
be asked what does that mean is he just
is that just the name he takes now I
mean does it have some kind of honorary
measure because there's no additional
power to go with it so what does it mean
that Kyle Rayner is ion and that was the
idea was to basically consolidate all
those different pot threats bring it
together and it's the guardians of the
universe basically saying Kyle Rayner is
now the torchbearer Kyle Rayner bears
the legacy of the Green Lantern Corps if
for any reason the Green Lantern Corps
is totally obliterated they're totally
wiped out of the garden to the universe
or kill the whole nine yards Kyle Rayner
is the only person who can resurrect
them from the dead he's the only person
that can bring them back and so that's
what the term torch bearer means that he
carries the mantle and the legacy of the
Green Lantern Corps and he will restore
them if anything ever happens now what
this also means is a Kyle Rayner is the
most
Green Lantern because if Kyle wayna were
to be killed for example and then the
Green Lantern Corps were to be wiped out
there'd be nobody to bring them back
there'd be nobody to resurrect him they
would just sort of be gone forever and
that would really be about it
but what it does from here is it
basically throws Kyle Rayner into the
fray and it makes him a central focal
point for Sinestro because now what it
means is that a commoner is this
important and if Kyle Rayner is
basically the torch bearer for the Green
Lantern's then now it is let's go get
Kyle Rayner we have to grab him we have
to corrupt him and swing him to our side
and that's one of the coolest aspect of
the other the whole Sinestro Corps war
is this like this race for Kyle Rayner
now of course after this information is
all dropped by the Guardians of the
Universe
Nero begins to detonate Nero begins to
explode and really almost you know wipes
everybody out but of course Kyle Rayner
uses this insane amount of power he has
by unlocking the full power of the star
heart as well as all the green lantern
energy he possesses and basically
confines all the energy of Nero back
down again but again this really kind of
brings Kyle Rayner back to having
someone that has an absurd amount of
power and it sets the stage for the idea
of Kyle Rayner being one of the sole
individuals out there who can resurrect
the Green Lantern core person of such
incredible and extreme power that almost
nobody can stop him again setting the
stage for the idea of Kyle Rayner
becoming the white lantern okay so
getting into Jeff Jones Green Lantern I
guess continuing on with Geoff Johns
Green Lantern we get into the origin of
the Star Sapphire so this is cool
because what geoff johns is gonna do is
actually retcon a lot of the existing
information with regard to star
sapphires but it's also really the first
time he's expanded on the emotional
spectrum and what I mean by that is when
he was doing his uh his Green Lantern
run he was doing a lot of things at the
same time in the immediate it was
focusing on stories here and there that
were kind of revamping characters so
going back and redoing the origin of Hal
Jordan introducing the star sapphires
and their new origin that kind of a
thing and the backdrop of it all this
Sinestro Corps was growing the Sinestro
Corps was expanding nobody really knew
about it I mean it was kind of there but
it was something that people weren't
wholly aware of what this does is this
says okay look you know here the new
version of the star sapphires and it
just kind of introduces this so Geoff
Johns can come back and reference it
later on now that's why I say this is
kind of a big deal because the star
sapphires have a pretty huge origin I
mean kind of going all the way back to
the Golden Age the star sapphires were
there
it wasn't really until DC showcased
number 22 in 1959 that the star
sapphires played more of a significant
role now keep in mind one of the whole
ideals with the star sapphires back then
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that here in a second but one of the
whole ideals of the star sapphires back
then was just kind of bolstering the
Green Lantern landscape but what this
does is it basically picks up with the
idea of Carol Ferris becoming a star
sapphire yet again and again this is a
media this is fast the star sapphire
just shows up says you've been a star
sapphire before you are the one person
above all others that Hal Jordan
cherishes you are going to become a star
sapphire and you are going to serve the
purpose of being one of us and helping
us to basically defeat Hal Jordan and
get our revenge and then kind of take
over the world and that sort of thing
now of course at this point we switch
over to cowgirl and that's one of the
reasons why I wanted to cover the
character of Jillian Pearlman in our
previous discussions we were talking
about how Jordan wanted that whole
relationship between the two of them and
you know how Jordans shortcomings and so
on and so forth because Jillian Pearlman
becomes the next star sapphire in the
sense that Carol Ferris kind of shows up
and begins freaking out and of course
immediately goes after Hal Jordan
immediately recognizing the star
sapphire on-site it leads to a bit of a
conflict between the two but the heart
of Hal Jordan is with Jillian Pearlman
remember Carol Ferris had made it quite
clear that there was not going to be a
relationship between her and Hal Jordan
there was in the past but it was really
one of those things works like what's in
the past is in the past let's leave that
then we are coworkers and that's really
the extent of it that's the limit of it
now for us the star sapphire really kind
of hits home at the idea then how George
instill cares about Carol Ferris and how
could he not I mean they simply just
have too much history together they've
been together for too long they were
really kind of associated with each
other too much they had a very physical
and a very passionate relationship
together so it only makes sense that
those feelings would be maintained but
recognizing that Hal Jordans heart at
least at the moment is with Jillian
chroman with cowgirl this star sapphire
abandons Carol Ferris and merges with
Jillian merges with cowgirl which in
turn makes her than the newest version
of the star sapphire now this is when we
get into Jeff Jones kind of going back
and changing things and that's why I
wanted to wait until this moment to sort
of bring this up again this is a quick
three issue story it's not long by any
standard of measurement but with the
original star sapphire not really the
original but with the Carol Ferris star
sapphire the idea was that at the time
Hal Jordan the Green Lantern was still
pretty much new and so because of that
the idea was to basically expand him
grow him you know get people introduced
to the new landscape of the Green
Lantern and what it meant but the other
half was to basically introduce kind of
an antithesis to the Green Lantern
itself now Sinestro had already been
established semester was the bad guy he
had a yellow ring green lanterns were
just weak to the color yellow for
whatever reason I mean we know now that
his parallax but at the time there
really was no definitive reason given
back then it was just their weakness is
the color yellow and that's just the way
it is and he just kind of had to accept
it and you know go with the stories
accordingly but that was the bad guy the
idea was to introduce somebody who could
potentially be a love interest or at the
very least somebody who could kind of
prey on the feelings of Hal Jordan and
that came in the form of his love
interest Carol Carol Farris now the way
that star sapphires functioned back then
in the 1950s and 1960s was that they
were basically just a race of women who
wanted to prove they were better than
guys and that was it like there was no
grandiose you know huge grand pooh-bah
think some massive background story that
was all there was to it they basically
were able to mimic the power of the
Green Lantern and Star Sapphire became
an enemy of Hal Jordan now this
eventually led him to characters like
Deborah Camille Darnell I think it was
who was a star sapphire at one point in
time it was always this reoccurring
theme that kept coming back and it was
an attempt by DC to always sort of
reinvigorate and revamp interest in the
Green Lantern landscape the problems
that it never really worked out because
at the end of the day there was really
no bump
there was no gumption behind the
character it was just an arbitrary
villain out there somewhere that no one
really understood or knew anything about
and so with geoff johns what he comes
back and he says okay that whole origin
of the Star Sapphire is just wanting to
be better than guys that's not the way
it works anymore the way it worked is
that in the beginning when the guardians
of the universe basically began the
process of shedding their emotion that
they went to all the members all these
different races and said look you guys
need to shed your emotion you know these
members of the guardians you have to
walk away from your emotion you have to
abandon you know the emotional spectrum
so that you can have logic and reason
that guides your lives there were some
that broke away and some that said no we
are not going to follow this path and
they began to experiment with different
types of emotions now a handful of these
we're you know a group of women who
basically began to really kind of travel
around the universe for billions of
years trying to find different aspects
of the emotional spectrum to tap into
remember the emotional spectrum is not
something you can just go and grab right
like you can't go to the corner store
and say I'd like the emotion of
if you don't mind it doesn't work that
way you know it's really one of those
things Reed is kind of have to unlock it
harness it tap into that power so to
speak and with these particulars a
miron's what they had done is they had
come across a planet whereby it was
really like the last remaining men and
women so to speak or the last male and
female and what they discovered is that
in their final moments the sort of Adam
and Eve Romeo and Juliet sort of
scenario you know assuming that they
were the last living members of their
race the lover for the two of them had
taken form in a physical object that was
basically more like a rock or a stone or
a gym of some kind and the result is
that it bonded itself with one of the
zamarons now this eventually led to the
formation of the xamarin culture I guess
you know the the star sapphire group
which in turn began the process of going
around and trying to find people you
know that could be used as their avatars
to basically expand their numbers which
led to them encountering Carol Ferris
now that part in terms of their numbers
growing and trying to expand and so on
that's Geoff Johns grabbing the original
Star Sapphire mythos but that's really
the only original aspect of it that he
grabs everything else is totally
different because of the fact that the
star sapphires believe that love is the
greatest of all the emotions what they
do is they basically a bond or at least
the star sapphire Bond's itself to a
host which in turn mates with somebody
in particular and then in cases all life
in this kind of gem construct basically
keeping it in a state of suspended
animation and so if we were to liken
this to like a crazy person
it would basically be like if somebody
believed that you were perfect the way
you are they loved you that much they
wanted to keep you perfect they would
encase you in suspended animation and
you would be stuck that way forever
almost turning you into kind of like a
trophy or a doll of some kind and so
because of that following the star
sapphires isn't necessarily death per se
it's kind of like living death in the
sense they basically encase entire
planets and living crystal and that's
the fate that befall --zz Hal Jordan
should he made with a particular star
sapphire and that's what makes them so
dangerous now again the star sapphires
are governed by love and compassion is
the overriding factor of who they are
much in the same way that the Red
Lanterns are governed by rage and anger
the star sapphires are the same way but
should Hal Jordan mate with Carol Ferris
as a star sapphire or Gillian Perlman as
a star sapphire it would basically
result in the complete conquering of the
planet earth the whole earth being
encased in crystal and that's really
about it and so it's always this
cat-and-mouse game when the star
sapphire will show up it'll chase down
Hal Jordan
he'll just kind of have to evade and
that'll be it now one of the other
things that Geoff Johns kind of does
here is he adds a little bit of comedy
in this you know we're cowgirl kind of
shows up tries to harness Hal Jordan is
this idea that like her her attraction
to him physical and otherwise
immediately seizes control and it's
almost kind of comedic you know it's
almost kind of funny in the sense that
it's just like all I'm running away from
the chick who's crazy and just won't let
me go but because of the power of the
star sapphire because of the fact that
it's really one of these things worse
like the ex-girlfriend versus the
current girlfriend it really just kind
of turns into a battle between Star
Sapphire and Carol Farris Carol Ferris
becomes a Green Lantern at the end of
the day however where Jillian Pearlman
is basically defeated ultimately this
leads into the arrival of the zamarons
and a battle between them and Hal Jordan
now again it's really this notion that
they intend to kind of take him down and
put him in a situation where they're
like look choose which one you're going
to mate with you're gonna mate with one
choose one of them or we're going to
kill you you know we're going to kill
either one of them and so you have to
choose now ultimately he chooses neither
he says no he hasn't chosen either one
of them and so because of this he
actually kind of runs up on one of those
a alien chicks and like kisses her
and so the star sapphire is like she's
chosen her you know and so the star
sapphire just kind of races off and
bonds with this this alien chick which
results in them having to forcefully
remove it meaning they have to basically
retreat and go back to their base of
operations but again this is not
designed to like establish Carol Ferris
as the new Star Sapphire going forward
it's basically designed to say here are
where the star sapphires are here are
what the star sapphire is about
basically saying we're going to see them
return we're gonna see them play a role
in the realm of Geoff Johns Green
Lantern again this is basically what he
did with a lot of these things for
example as part of this story in the
backup features there was tales of the
Sinestro Corps basically us learning
about the different members of the
Sinestro Corps that have existed over
the years and the purpose that they
serve why they were chosen so on and so
forth kind of a cool little series of
stories we might cover those once we get
closer to Sinestro Corps war but
ultimately when they remove this Star
Sapphire gem from the head of this exam
Iran who's been chosen again this is
Geoff Johns building up what we're going
to see with the Green Lantern's it's
really the first introduction that we
get with regards to everything else
that's going on we have of course what
looks like the orange lantern us don't
we end up having me of course the Green
Lantern's and then we have the star
sapphires but there's also four
aspects of the emotional spectrum and so
it was again geoff johns basically
saying hey look guys here's the first
time we're really delving into the
origin of another aspect of the
emotional spectrum but there's so much
more to come later on down the line
clusters also talk of a war of course we
know that kind of being the Sinestro
Corps war slash you know blackest night
and so again it's basically building up
and sank the Green Lantern mythos as you
know it is about to expand by a huge
margin there's going to be so much more
that's introduced then you can imagine
at this point in time so again it was
really kind of setting the stage sort of
wetting our palate giving us an idea of
what things were coming later on down
the line which of course as we know ends
up turning out to be pretty awesome so
in the event again this was a pretty
short story I mean there's only three
issues long not a whole lot of
explanation they're really just kind of
a chance to sort of give us a new origin
for a group that had previously existed
kind of bolster their ranks show us that
there's more to the emotional spectrum
but uh but yeah guys anyway if you are
new here to come let's explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the robb cork you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]